Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, hast du eigentlich was gegen Schwaben.
Ich gegen Schwamm, ich habe da nichts gegen Schwaben, einige meiner besten Zahnärzte und Vermieter sind Schwaben.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertundzweiundfünfzig vom ersten Juli zwanzig zwanzig. Wir haben uns das erste halbe Jahr durchgerettet, haben's überlebt. Ist das schon mal was?
Du musst mir das nachher auch noch erklären hier mit dieser mit der Mehrwertsteuer, mit der Umsatzsteuer. Ich kann keine Rechnungen mehr schreiben.
Das äh ist nicht so schön. Da musst du, musst du Update laden.
Äh gibt's ein Update von dem von dem Programm, was das dann einfach automatisch macht? Geil.
Ja. Tipps habe ich auch schon installiert.
Alles klar. Prima. Dann schreibe ich erstmal gleich eine Rechnung. An irgendeinem Schwaben.
Lina, du musst dich jetzt äh du musst dich, du musst das natürlich jetzt gerade äh zehren, aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal hier unsere ähm unsere dritte Position nochmal äh benennen, denn wir haben,
Besuch. Der Thomas ist mal wieder dabei. Hallo, Thomas.
Hallo guten Morgen.
Genau. Schöne Grüße nach. Wo bist du in Wien? In Wien,
Genau. Frisch vom Termin und mit ganz viel äh Themen im Gepäck mit anderen Worten. Heute ist ein bisschen äh liegt der Schwerpunkt ein wenig auf Österreich, aber auch auf Europa, aber natürlich auch auf Schwaben.
Stimmt's? Weil wir haben ja Post bekommen. Linus.
Wir haben Post bekommen, ja? Also Einhörer haben wir jetzt verloren.
Nee, wir haben relativ viel äh Feedback aus äh Stuttgart bekommen und zwar das wichtigste Feedback kam äh in meinen Augen äh zu Term Hidor.
Der und schrieb, äh wir haben uns ja in der letzten Sendung über den kaputten VW-Bus der Polizei unterhalten und Term Hidor schreibt uns hallo, VW-Bus, wir sind in Stuttgart, in welchen ärmlichen Gegenden fährt die Polizei denn bitte VW?
Der der Bus ist ein Benz und heißt Vito. Neuer Sendungstitel bitte. Ja.
Mercedes, ja? In Stuttgart fahren die natürlich nicht ähm niedersächsische.
Im Automobile. Das ist äh das ist klar. Aber ähm ja, man muss natürlich dann schon auch erkennen, VW-Bus ist halt eine.
Ist halt einfach eine eigene eine eigene Kategorie für sich.
Und äh der auch Mercedes hat da ja nur versucht einen VW-Bus zu bauen. Mal gucken, ob Mercedes vielleicht irgendwann auch nochmal versucht, Elektro-KFZ zu bauen, dann.
Das wäre mal was.
Könnte sich der könnte sich der Standort da vielleicht sogar halten. Ähm.
Mit Anhängerkupplung bitte. Aber ich möchte auch nochmal betonen, dass wir natürlich auch alle Schwaben ganz lieb haben und nicht nur die Schwaben, auch die Baden. Die Badener. Oder sagt man.
Heißen die, glaube ich. Ah, da hatten wir schon mal, da hatten wir doch schon mal irgendwie, da habe ich, habe ich Badensa gesagt und dann hat sich wieder die eine Hälfte aufgeregt und die andere Hälfte auch und.
Man kann es euch auch nicht recht machen.
Leute, ihr.
Da bleiben wir einfach bleiben wir einfach bei unserem Berliner äh Schmäh und meckern einfach über alles, weil so ist es hier einfach. Ja, man muss einfach über alles äh meckern, wir können nichts anderes.
Nein, also wir haben auch wir haben auch sehr schöne Musikempfehlungen bekommen, Freundeskreis, ne, Max Herre und so. Schöner Hip Hop und äh,
Darüber hinaus sehr viel Instrumental auch gearbeitet. Und mir wurde dann auch das war ein bisschen peinlich. Ich wurde dann daran erinnert, wer denn die Punkband aus Stuttgart ist, beziehungsweise aus Sindelfingen. Das ist natürlich wieso.
Mhm. Nö. Ich hab's nicht so mit Punk. Auch nicht.
Doch, kennst du? Tim.
Ich bin da so ein äußerst techno äh.
Eine Revolution für den Frieden und die Freiheit, eine Revolution für die Anarchie? Ja, musst du doch kennen.
Mich nicht so viel in so linken Kellern rumgetrieben wie du.
Da hätten wir auch noch ein schönes äh so ein schönes Auto hier, der diesen ähm ja dieser Schlachtrufsong, die letzte Sau oder so. Das würde eigentlich zu dem das würde eigentlich zu dem Tönnies passen als Autor. Das machen wir als Auto-T.
Gerade mal Frieden mit dem Süden geschlossen und dann aufm Westen eintrümmern.
Nein, die wollen, wir, die Schwaben, die haben zu Recht,
ja? Ich meine, Digitalisierung findet da ja nicht statt. Insofern finden die halt auch in ähm in äh Logbuch Netzwerken statt und haben die zu Recht auf Kulturhauptstadt Stuttgart.
Und Sindelfingen hingewiesen. Wir machen einen schönen, wir machen schöne, schöne, schöne Musik aus Badewürtteberg. Machen wir jetzt hier am Ende. Ähm dann hatten wir Feedback zu.
CWA-Auswertung.
Corona one App. Da du hast dir das angeschaut, Tim, ich habe das nämlich schon hier im UKW Corona Bye Weekly oder gehört?
Genau.
Ähm zwei Leute haben da dashop Boards gebaut.
Genau, also es gibt jetzt verschiedene Leute, die sich halt äh einfach mal der öffentlich verfügbaren Daten äh annehmen und die versuchen, so gut es möglich ist, da in irgendeiner Form Zahlen draus zu generieren, die einen weiter bringen
Da gibt's ähm zwei Sachen. Ähm ich weiß gar nicht, wie heißt der? Ähm.
Mensch, der sich gerade da miteinander, also.
Wir verlinken mal alle, alle, alle beiden verschiedene äh Auswertungen, kurz gesagt, die laden sich einfach diese öffentlich verfügbaren
Diagnoseschlüssel runter und versuchen daraus halt Trends abzubilden und vor allem auch abzuleiten, wie viele Leute denn nun tatsächlich diese App benutzt haben. Das ist so nach dieser,
Schätzungen derzeit so hundertfünfundzwanzig Meldungen, die also über die App gemacht wurden.
Anderen Worten das Ding läuft und wird auch benutzt und äh ich hätte da auch äh Paddel hatte das rausgesucht. Also es ist ungefähr fünf Prozent der Leute, die als Neuinfiziert gemeldet sind, benutzen auch diese App derzeit.
Was jetzt noch steigerungs.
Zur Meldung, zur äh lösen eine Meldung aus. Es kann ja sein, dass also muss ja immer genau wir müssen ja hier genau sein. Also lösen eine Meldung über diese App aus, was im Zweifelsfall auch bedeutet, dass sie diese App benutzen.
Ja, gut. Also, davon.
Könnte ja noch sein, dass noch mehr Leute die App benutzen, aber sagen.
Gut, aber das ist auf jeden Fall schöne äh Arbeit und ähm wie ich da auch mit Pavel rausgearbeitet habe. Eigentlich wird hier mal wieder die Tätigkeit der der öffentlichen Behörden äh gemacht, weil solche Zahlen.
Könnten die noch sehr viel einfacher und sehr viel genauer veröffentlichen und da sehe ich auch überhaupt gar kein Problem damit, das zu tun.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, wie das ist, so mit Open Data und Behörden und so. Das äh braucht noch ein bisschen. Mal gucken, was kommt.
Also verlinkt haben wir dann die beiden Dashboards von Michael und Jan und ihre jeweiligen Kommentare und Gitter Pages dazu.
Ähm dann habe ich noch per E-Mail von Philipp äh eine Meldung bekommen und zwar geht's immer noch oder was heißt immer noch, geht es hier jetzt um diese,
Thema App Gesetz, ja? Wir hatten als der Vorschlag äh aus der Gruppe um Malte Engler kam, dass er hier auch grundsätzlich positiv bewertet. Das kam,
vor der äh bevor es die App überhaupt gab, da war, denke ich, auch die notwendige Debatte, ja, ähm.
Und vor allem da hätte so ein Gesetz auch wirklich noch wirken können, weil es eben eine, ja, gesetzliche Grundlage für auch Vertrauen geschaffen.
Hätte. Ähm.
In der letzten Sendung haben wir dann wie ich gesagt, es wäre doch auch einfach mal schön, wenn sich alle mal an die demokratische Maßgabe halten würden, dass es einfach freiwillig ist und man weder die Leute zwingt, die App zu installieren, noch die Leute zwingt, sich die App nicht zu installieren.
Dazu kommentiert Philipp. Das ist juristisch unterkomplex. Die Datenverarbeitung in der Verantwortlichkeit des Robert Kors Institutes basiert auf der Einwilligung der Nutzerinnen.
Diese müssen, diese muss, um wirksam zu sein, freiwillig erfolgen.
Nun ist es aber so, dass der oder die Arbeitgeberin zum Beispiel in einem Krankenhaus die App Nutzung Arbeitsrechtlich rechtmäßig anordnen kann.
Der Punkt ist, dass damit die Freiwilligkeit der Einwilligung futsch ist und die Verarbeitung des RKI-Rechtswidrig wird.
Die demokratische Maßgabe der Freiwilligkeit ist eher die von vornherein verfehlte Wahl der Einwilligung als Rechtsgrundlage seitens der Bundesregierung. Hätte man das
Begleitgesetz zur App erlassen, wäre dieses die Rechtsgrundlage der Datenverarbeitung. Man müsste jetzt nicht irgendwelche Appelle machen, die rechtlich wirkungslos sind.
Darin hat mich deine äh Aussage.
An die Datenschutzkonferenz erinnert, die auch schon auf diese Weise unterkomplex war. Ich versteh, also ich.
Erkenne, dass das auf jeden Fall oder ich erkenne an, dass das irgendwie juristisch komplex ist, äh was ich mich echt frage, ist ähm.
Müssen wir jetzt das Robert Koch-Institut verhaften.
Ja welche Daten der Nutzerinnen so also gar keine erhoben.
Ich denke, dass dass das ein, das hat das tatsächliche Problem. Man sieht's ja irgendwie, wenn man sich hier dieses äh Interview mit Sarah Wagenknecht anhört und man sieht's auch
Ich will da jetzt gar nicht sagen, wo mir Leute auffallen, denen ich schon vielleicht,
Auch persönlich selber mal die Funktionsweise der App erklärt habe, die noch immer Fragen zu dieser App stellen oder Vorstellungen von deren Funktionalität oder nicht Funktionalität haben.
Die ähm,
sehr weit davon entfernt sind, was äh als gesichertes Wissen über diese App äh verfügbar ist und auch auf vielen Kanälen verbreitet wurde. Und ähm dass das
glaube ich nach wie vor, dass das tatsächlich das größere Problem ist. Also wahrscheinlich muss man da doch mehr noch mal drüber aufklären, was
Funktioniert, also es ich bin tatsächlich erstaunt, was für.
Auch heute noch in Innenkreisen, wo ich's nicht erwarten würde, für Fehlkonzepte von der Funktionsweise dieser App vorherrschen. Das muss ich dann halt auch als mein persönliches Scheitern zur Kenntnis nehmen, weil ich habe jetzt irgendwie
drei Monate lang nur erklärt wie diese App funktioniert, das habe ich offenbar dann nicht gut genug gemacht.
Wollen auch nicht verstehen.
Oder an den falschen Stellen. Von mir aus sollen die auch ein Gesetz machen. Ich fänd's ja gut, aber ähm ich sehe irgendwie gerade nicht, dass das passiert.
Voll das Problem kenne ich auch von äh den den Wortmeldungen, die sich dann irgendwelche Dinge aus den Haaren zu Hause, was diese App irgendwie angeblich noch alles tut oder nicht kann oder an Überwachungsfunktionalität.
Ähm das ist in Österreich, glaube ich, noch mal schlimmer als in Deutschland. Ähm zu der Frage der Freiwilligkeit ähm das, was der Komment,
der Philipp hier gesagt hat, stimmt schon, also wenn der Arbeitgeber die App verpflichtet oder zum Beispiel, man stellt sich vor, ähm die kommt in die Hausordnung von äh einer Veranstaltung oder von einem Geschäft
dann wäre die Datenschutzrechtliche Grundlage für die Verarbeitung weg. Das stimmt schon.
Ähm aber äh leider kann man das ja trotzdem im Zweifelsfall nicht verhindern, weil das sind dann irgendwelche ähm,
Gebäude, wo man reingehen will und in Hausordnungen kann man mal schon so alles reinschreiben.
Und äh deswegen sind äh wir in Österreich auch noch an so einem Gesetz dran, dass über Diskriminierungsrecht die Freiwilligkeit einfach absichert,
dass wir gar nicht erst in diese Situation reinkommen,
und dadurch bindest du dann auch private auch in ihren AGBs und Hausordnungen keinen App-Zwang zu machen, weil auch wenn der Staat das nicht will, jeder private könnte es theoretisch tun
für sinnvoll halte ich das trotzdem nicht.
Gut, also da der Philipp hatte auch nochmal einen Blogpost zugeschrieben, wer sich noch insgesamt mit dem Corinna Warn-App Begleitgesetz auseinandersetzt, den haben wir dann auch in den.
Shownotes verlinkt und dann würde ich sagen, immer wenn Thomas in der Sendung ist, gibt es ja Informationen.
Aus Europa und aus Österreich und eines der wichtigsten Themen, die eigentlich ja zwanzig zwanzig auf dem.
Schirm standen, ist ja der Digital Services act. Du hast da.
Auf dem sechsunddreißig C drei ja auch schon drüber vorgetragen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche zusammen mit Chloe.
Von Edri.
Und jetzt musst du es trotzdem nochmal erklären.
Ähm ja, also äh vor ein paar Sendungen habt ihr ja drüber gesprochen, dass die Konsultation der EU-Kommission jetzt endlich veröffentlicht wurde und ähm
Das ist sozusagen die erste Möglichkeit, sich bei diesem Gesetz zu beteiligen. Noch bevor das Gesetz wirklich von der Kommission veröffentlicht wird, gibt's eine Konsultation, wo wir alle unsere Meinung sagen können
und nachdem das Thema so wichtig für die Netzpolitik ist und uns auch noch so lange beschäftigen wird, ähm ist jetzt noch ein guter Zeitpunkt, drüber zu reden.
Vor allem in der EU ist es so,
egal was du machst, um irgendwie so eine Position im Gesetzgebungsprozess durchzubringen je früher du das machst, umso effektiver ist es.
Also jetzt gerade haben wir noch super viel Impact mit dem, was wir sagen. Und je länger das Gesetz verhandelt wird, je näher wir zu der endgültigen Verabschiedung kommen, umso kleiner wird der Spielraum umso größer müssen die Anstrengungen sein, um noch was zu bewegen.
Deswegen ist die Zeit jetzt grade eigentlich sehr spannend. Ähm,
und vielleicht sollten wir aber noch kurz erklären, worum's dabei überhaupt geht. Ähm also der sogenannte Digital Services Act
ähm ist eine Reform der E-Commerce Richtlinie, also dem Haftungsregime im Internet. Es ist ja so, wenn du,
ähm ein Internetprovider bist und Daten durchleitest,
haftest du nicht für die Bombenanleitung, die du überträgst. Wenn du ein Oster bist und jemanden verkaufst, haftest du nicht für das, was deine Kunden dann dort ablegen und ins Netz stellen
Und auch für Plattformen wie YouTube oder Facebook, die haften nicht für die Inhalte ihrer User.
Das ist so, weil wir seit den Zweitausender Jahren ein Gesetz dafür haben auf EU-Ebene und das wird jetzt reformiert und da hinein spielen all die Probleme, die wir mit großen
Internetplattformen haben. Und ähm diese Probleme drehen sich dann rundum.
Netz, Fake News, das sind so die in der politischen Debatte, gerade auch ähm rund um Corona oder Black Lives Matter wird das ja auch sehr heiß diskutiert. Es geht aber auch um äh Fragen des Urheberrechts. Es geht um Fragen,
wie wir prinzipiell auch mit diesen Plattformen,
ähm operieren und wieso wir da immer so einen Login Effekt haben, äh sprich es äh wird dieses Gesetz, wird auch von manchen Leuten in der EU-Kommission als Internet bezeichnet. Also es sind ganz viele grundlegende Fragen, die damit
gelöst werden sollen. Und ähm
Gleichzeitig gibt's auch noch ganz viel Konsumentenschutzfragen und Markenrecht, was da reinspielt. Die Gesetzgebung der Höchstgerichte, die wir haben, ähm haben dann so Namen wie Loryal versus eBay. Also das sind äh auch äh ganz klassische Fragen von
physischen Dinge, die übers Internet verdickt werden, aber eBay hatte eine Anzeige geschalten, sollten die nicht mithaften. Auch solche Fragen spielen da rein. Ähm.
Ja das äh Gesetz wird wahrscheinlich Ende des Jahres kommen.
Und uns dann für mehrere Jahre beschäftigen. Also drei bis fünf Jahre ist so eine ähm realistische Zeitschätzung. Das äh wird dann nicht schnell gehen, befürchte ich.
Dass man also mit das das der Gesetz wird kommen der erste Entwurf wird kommen und die Diskussion wird dann fünf Jahre gehen oder wie meinst du jetzt diese.
Ja
Also seitdem seit dem Amtsantritt von Ursula von der Leyen. Äh wir hatten ja zweitausendneunzehn EU-Wahl. Da ist ganz klar mit dem mit dem Arbeitsprogramm der Kommission, dass das kommen wird. Ähm und äh
das Gesetz äh wird eben erst Ende dieses Jahres der Öffentlichkeit vorgestellt, dann wissen wir mal, was die Kommission sich vorstellt und äh die die drei bis fünf Jahre beziehen sich auf den Prozess
danach, wenn das Ding durchs Parlament und durch den Rat äh muss und dann am Ende ist äh
Der Trilog, also dann sitzen wieder Kommission, Parlament und Rat, also die EU-Mitgliedstaaten an einem Tisch und verhandeln das Ganze aus.
Ähm und in der Phase ähm das äh wird insgesamt, würde ich meinen, auf jeden Fall diese ganze EU-Gesetzgebungsperiode dauern. Einfach weil's so kompliziert ist. Ähm das sind jetzt nur Schätzungen, aber aus Erfahrung heraus würde ich, würde ich damit operieren.
Und ähm wie gesagt aber was jetzt im Juni passiert ist, ist dass die Konsultation der EU Kommission äh gestartet wurde und da kann man sich beteiligen. Das ist einfach über ein Onlineformular möglich. Ähm
Das Ganze ist sehr umfangreich. Wir haben hier neunundfünfzig Seiten an äh reinen Fragen, die zu beantworten sind
Fragen sind teilweise sehr konfus, dann wieder auch sehr, sehr super spezifisch. Äh es haben schon einige Leute gemeint, dass das
ja nicht sonderlich äh zugänglich ist. Und deswegen wird's auch noch eine Ausfüllhilfe von edri und von Epizentor Works auf deutsch geben, wie man sich bei dieser Konsultation beteiligen kann.
Ähm und wie gesagt, da ist der erste Moment, der auch noch sehr effektiv ist, äh sich dran zu beteiligen, was man sich da vorstellt
und ähm parallel gibt's auch noch was anderes, das passiert. Und zwar im Parlament ähm.
Da ist ja jetzt grade noch nichts los. Die Parlamentarier wurden neu gewählt äh und die haben vielleicht noch ein paar Gesetze von der letzten Gesetzgebungsperiode, die sie fertig machen, aber noch ist ja nix aus der Kommission rausgepurzelt, an dem die arbeiten können.
Und deswegen äh beschäftigen die sich selbst mit sogenannten,
Inny-Reports oder Initiative. Also das sind einfach nur so Meinungsbildungen innerhalb des Parlaments, äh wo man äh über einen Bericht streitet, der zum Beispiel sagt, der Rechtsausschuss meint,
Dinge sollten in den Digital Servers Act
äh der Bildermarktausschuss meint, diese Dinge sollten in den ähm Digital Services Act. Und da da ja aber auch die Abgeordneten in ihrem Parteien mit ihrem Club stärken drüber abstimmen,
ist das ein recht spannendes Austesten, welche Ideen mehrheitsfähig sind. Und äh da kann man dann auch schon abschätzen,
Wie positionieren sich die Liberalen, wie die Konservativen, was denken die Sozialdemokraten? Und ähm da kann man sehr nah mit der Lupe auch hinschauen, weil alle sozusagen schon mal grob abgestimmt haben zu dem Thema und die Debatte dadurch auch mal ins Laufen kommen.
Sind da sozusagen die ganzen Maximalforderungen, die man dann erstmal erhält.
Ja, wobei die die Maximalforderungen auch noch eine Mehrheit im Parlament brauchen.
Also du kannst jetzt mit einem ähm es wäre ganz spannend, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jemand probiert hat, aber so in den Report mal reinschreiben, wir wollen Facebook zerschlagen,
und mal schauen ob das mehrheitsfähig im im Europa Parlament wäre. Wäre eigentlich ganz lustig.
Und in Wirklichkeit geht's aber um Texte, die halt wirklich so Prinzipien aufstellen, was man sich erhofft von dem Gesetz und auch welche Ideen man gut findet.
Diese Ideen kommen bei diesem Gesetz auch grade sehr stark von unserer Community, also der netzpolitischen Zivilgesellschaft.
Die vor allem auch so wichtige Themen wie Intooperabilität nach vorne stellt, also dass du diese großen Datensilos aufbrichst und es ermöglichst, dass ähm du zum Beispiel als Startup auch ähm,
deinen eigenen Twitter-Kleid machen kannst
oder ähm dass du vielleicht WhatsApp interoperabel machst, sodass andere Messenger auch ähm Nachrichten dorthin schicken können, ohne dass du dir selber WhatsApp installieren müsstest. Ähm dieartige Prinzipien werden diskutiert und
wurden bisher auch sehr gut angenommen vom Europaparlament.
Und auch zu den Fragen, wie man mit äh illegalen Inhalten umgehen soll, ähm haben wir sogar recht guten,
auch auch von von uns schon in die Kompromissvorschläge für den Imker ähm Report reinbekommen. Sprich, da ist schon sehr viel am Laufen und die.
Beginnt jetzt Fahrt aufzunehmen und wird die nächsten paar Jahre nur intensiver werden.
Und ähm es sind ähm dann auch große Fragen, die,
noch irgendwie ungelöst sind und zwar es gibt inzwischen ganz gute Vorstellungen auf allen Seiten, wie man mit illegalen Inhalten umgeht, wie man mit legalen um Inhalten umgeht, die aber vielleicht gegen die AGBs verstoßen
was so noch spannend ist, ist die Frage, ähm wie will man denn überhaupt Algorithmen regulieren? Also gerade,
da gibt's ja auch Studien dazu die Videos die einem YouTube empfiehlt sind einzig und allein darauf ausgelegt dass man möglichst viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt, also dass man möglichst lange auf YouTube ist und mit einem mehr Werbung angezeigt werden kann,
Selbiges im Facebook Newsfeed. Ahn die einzigen Kriterien, nach denen dieser Algorithm,
optimiert sind, sind eigentlich Sessionlänge, also je länger du dort drauf schaust, umso besser ist es für die Plattform, da kann man sich als Gesellschaft fragen, ob das wirklich der richtige Maßstab,
und ähm da gibt's halt auch Vorschläge, auch der aus der Medienregulierungsecke, äh die man sich anschauen muss,
aber da habe ich auch noch nicht so die wirklich gute Lösung gefunden. Und genau solche
konkreten Vorschläge sind jetzt gerade was erarbeitet wird. Die Kommission ist dann aber äh ja die einzige Institution mit Vorschlagsrecht.
Die äh entscheiden wird, was dann wirklich ins Gesetz reinkommt.
Zumindest in die erste Version davon. Das wird sich noch massiv ändern. Im Laufe des Gesetzgebungsprozesses, aber eine der Fragen, die wahrscheinlich gleich bleiben wird, ist, wer denn überhaupt mit der Umsetzung dieses Gesetzes beauftragt wird
also äh für Deutschland gesprochen, liegt das bei den Landesmedienanstalten, ähm liegt das bei,
ähm den den Datenschutzbehörden gibt mir das eben deiner komplett neuen Behörde, will man da überhaupt was nationales haben oder ist nicht Gescheiter, wenn man auf EU-Ebene
Regulator macht. Ähm also gerade diese Frage, wie man das durchsetzt, ist äh super wichtig dafür.
Weil äh ich kann aus eigener Erfahrung sagen, nichts ist äh deprimierender als wenn du erlebst, dass du jahrelang an einem Gesetz arbeitest und dann am Ende wird's einfach nicht durchgesetzt, weil die Behörden, die es in der Hand hätten
kein Interesse daran haben, ihren Job zu machen. Das haben wir leider in der Netzotralität zum Beispiel in Portugal gesehen oder im Daten,
sind wir das immer wieder, weil die irische Datenschutzbehörde sich quer stellt. Da hat ja Max auch schon ganz viele Kämpfe gefochten, um die zu bewegen. Und äh wenn wir das mit dem nicht richtig hinbekommen
dann wird es halt eine Behörde geben, die ähm von der Industrie eingekocht ist,
und äh dann halt das Minimum tun wird, was das Gesetz ja eigentlich auftragen würde.
Und man hört zum Beispiel auch gerade, dass so Ärger, das ist der ähm Dachverband der Medienregulierungsbehörden, dass die sehr, sehr nahe an der Verlagsbranche ist und
äh zum Beispiel auch Facebook äh findet, dass das die richtige Behörde wäre, was für jeden ein Warnsignal sein sollte. Ähm,
Medienregulierungsbehörden vielleicht nicht die beste Wahl sind in dem Thema. Ähm und ja, also das das äh ist so ungefähr, wo wir stehen.
Ist das ein Novum, das jetzt im Rahmen einer solchen Gesetzesinitiative auch mit beschlossen wird, wo das dann letztlich umgesetzt werden soll oder ist das jetzt eigentlich normal oder wird das nicht generell immer den Ländern überlassen?
Ähm unterschiedlich. Ähm also bei vielen EU-Gesetzen ist es so, dass die EU das äh offen lässt. Bei Netzotralität war es einfach so, dass die EU Verordnung vorschreibt, National Competent of Forities. Also.
Irgendeiner kompetente, nationale Stelle soll das Gesetz umsetzen.
Es in Deutschland ähm die Bundesnetzagentur in Österreich die RTR, oft sind das unabhängige Behörden. In Dänemark und Spanien sind aber die Telekom-Ministerien zuständig dafür, Netzzentralität umzusetzen. Was dazu führt, dass,
die überhaupt nichts tun und ähm User, Internet-User auch keine Möglichkeit haben, sich wirklich zu beschweren. Ähm also man kann da viel falsch machen.
Und äh wenn die EU sagt, ähm irgendwas Nationales soll das regeln, wirkt's halt komplett in der Hand der Mitgliedstaaten. Die EU kann äh nicht oder kaum vorgeben, wie nationale Behörden,
strukturiert sein sollen. Sie kann vorgeben, dass sie unabhängig sein müssen, aber das tut sie nicht immer.
Ähm beim Datenschutz hat sie das gemacht, auch schon in der ähm ursprünglichen äh Datenschutzrichtlinie von neunzehnfünfundneunzig stand drin, dass Datenschutzbehörden unabhängig sein müssen.
Und mit der Datenschutzgrundverordnung.
Hat man sich mehr getraut. Da war ja dieses Problem mit die Iren nix schon bekannt und deswegen hat man da einen Mechanismus eingeführt, dass wenn eine nationale Behörde wirklich nachhaltig,
ihren Job nicht macht, dass man da so viel U-Ebene eskalieren kann und da gibt's dann ein European Datection Board, dass die nationalen Behörden überstimmen kann,
und ihnen auch gewisse Fälle wegnehmen kann. Ähm das ist noch nie passiert. In den äh mehr als zwei Jahren, seit wir jetzt äh die DSGVO haben
ähm aber theoretisch hat man das im EU-Gesetz schon mitgedacht, dass manchmal national nichts passiert und deswegen muss man schauen,
Uploadfilter ist das übrigens auch grad eine Frage,
gibt's auch Beschwerdemechanismen, die die Richtlinie vorsieht, aber wo man sich dann wirklich konkret beschweren kann und ob das in Irland ist oder irgendwo national,
vor einem auch wirklich geholfen wird. Ähm das obliegte Mitgliedstaaten und da wird auch gerade gekämpft.
Und was was würdest du dir denn am liebsten vorstellen? Also äh wäre eine Möglichkeit, auch so eine europäische Behörde, die sowas macht oder ist es äh sinnlos?
Wir haben ja im Sommer zwei neunzehn schon unseren Vorschlag auf Plattform dot EU ähm vorgestellt und
ich bin immer erstaunt, wie lang äh lieb ich der ist, was wir da drinnen gefordert haben, was auch das ist, was Idri inzwischen fordert, ist eine ähm äh europäische Behörde
einen Plattformregulator, der wirklich äh für Plattformen zuständig ist und ähm sich um die Einhaltung von,
kümmert wie Transparenz vorgaben. Ähm wenn du äh illegale Inhalte notifizierst, dass es da gibt, also dass du,
so ein bissel Rechtsstaatlichkeit hast und dich zum Beispiel auch wenn jemand meint, das war eine Urberechtsverletz.
Dass du dich wehren kannst und sagst, äh nee, das ist mein Inhalt, der soll oben bleiben und das ist äh,
sozusagen ein sauberes Verfahren gibt. Das sollte bei so einer Behörde liegen. Ähm so einer Behörde sollte sich auch eben um Algorithmen kümmern unserer Meinung nach, um äh die ganzen Themen im Werbemarkt. Das wird auch ein großes Thema sein
und äh das sehen wir am besten geregelt bei einer europäischen Behörde.
Wichtig ist, dass wir diese Behörde aber nicht dafür zuständig sehen, dass die dann über einzelne Inhalte entscheidet. Weil das geht auf europäischer Ebene nicht.
Kannst auch Meinungsfreiheit, das ist ja auf EU-Ebene, auch nicht harmonisiert, nur national verstehen. Ja, vielleicht ist das,
in in in Deutschland ein Witz, aber in Dänemark wär's eine Beleidigung. Ja, wie willst du das als europäische Behörde feststellen, auch ohne dass du den kulturellen Kontext kennst.
Also grundsätzlich um den Prozess vielleicht mal zusammenzufassen, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe. Es gibt jetzt erst mal Meinungsbildung, was da so drin sein sollte primär in den Fraktionen. Das muss dann allerdings vom Parlament als solches als Vorschlag
für die Kommission beschlossen werden, dann sammelt die Kommission das alles ein, äh kombiniert das mit ihren eigenen Vorstellungen und,
Wie das dann eben so ist, macht einen Gesetzesvorschlag, der dann halt wieder in die Parlamente geht.
Genau. Und dazwischen auch noch die Konsultation und das ist der Teil, wo wir uns alle noch beteiligen können. Die läuft noch bis zum achten September.
Also es ist noch Zeit und ähm auf wird's Ausfüllhilfen geben, wenn man sich nicht selber durch die neunundfünfzig Seiten arbeiten will.
Nimmst du den Leuten den Spaß sozusagen daran?
Wer daran Spaß hat, der kann sich gerne austoben. Ähm es ist wirklich nichts sonderlich zugänglich, muss ich sagen, aber es ist auf jeden Fall sinnvoll, da drauf zu schauen. Der Link ist natürlich in den Shownotes.
Und ähm da es gibt auch Links auf den Dokumentpool von
Das ist ein super Blogpost, der auch über Jahre hinweg jetzt aktuell sein wird mit allen möglichen ähm Dokumenten, auch eben diesen ganzen In-Reports, des Parlaments, von denen ich gesprochen habe. Ähm da kann man sehr gut verfolgen, was passiert
und ähm,
Ja, also wer jetzt dabei ist bei dem Fall, hat auch den Vorteil, dass es sich später besser auskennt damit. Also diese diese Geschichte des Gesetzgebungsprozesses ist auf EU-Ebene,
super aufschlussreich, wenn man dann wirklich auch weiß, wie ähm Dinge gemeint waren.
Und es gibt noch einen Österreich-Aspekt, auf den ich zu sprechen kommen wollte. Ich war vor einer Woche bei unserer Europaministerin Ed Stadler, ähm auf einem Termin zum Digital Services act und habe dort auch gelernt,
man an einem Gesetz zu Netzwerkdurchsetzung in Österreich arbeitet. Also das Netz DG wurde ja in Deutschland schon breit diskutiert,
und sowas soll auch in Österreich kommen.
Und darin wird jetzt gerade gearbeitet wie sinnvoll das ist, wenn jetzt eh bald ein EU-Gesetz kommt, kann man da hinstellen, aber Sie haben sich das schon fix vorgenommen und.
Ähm ja da tut sich national einiges. In Frankreich gab's auch vor kurzem ein Urteil, dass so ein französisches ähm,
Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ähm in großen Teilen aufgehoben hat, das sogenannte. Ähm also dieses ganze Thema, was müssen Plattformen eigentlich tun und wie sollen sie mit illegalen oder unliebsamen Inhalten umgehen.
Ähm ist auf vielen Ebenen breit diskutiert und ähm insofern ist die EU hier auch im Zugzwang, weil wenn wir jetzt noch ein Jahr warten, dann gibt's zu viele nationale Gesetze, dass sich die EU auch mit ihrem Ansatz nicht mehr durchsetzen kann.
Hm
Äh nur noch mal zum Zusammenfassen, weil da jetzt auch viele Vergleiche zu Netzneutralität und jeweils auch schon wieder äh in Deutschland bestehenden ähm Gesetzen Bezug nimmst.
Es soll sich schon, weil du jetzt irgendwie auch noch grundgesetz äh der neue Verfassung für das Internet. Es geht primär um die Rechte und Pflichten von Plattformen.
Plattformen, beziehungsweise Dienste, Anbietern im Internet, ne.
Genau. Also es geht eigentlich.
Um den Scope nochmal so ein bisschen dazu.
Ja, ja, das ist eine.
Oder auszuleuchten.
Das ist ja gut, wenn das nicht klar war, also es geht mit Plattformen ist gemeint, alles was User-Generrated-Content hat. Also von Rezepte, Plattformen äh bis Facebook.
Wird da alles mehr oder weniger mit hineinfallen. Und äh natürlich ist und das
dürfte auch schon Konsens sein, ähm dass man, dass man da äh für die großen Plattformen eigene Regeln macht, als wie für die Kleinen. Und für die Kleinen will man keine überbordene Regulierung haben. Aber prinzipiell
ist schon alles im Netz, äh was irgendwie mit illegalen Inhalten zu tun hat,
von dem Haftungsregime, von diesem Gesetz betroffen. Ähm und äh ich sage mal so, der Konsens ist oder da, wo man sich streitet,
ist bei den Websites, die mit äh Userrated Content arbeiten oder den,
die das tun. Ähm dass man jetzt irgendwie einen klassischen Hoster oder einen ISP für die wird wahrscheinlich alles so bleiben wie bisher.
Jetzt ist ja die, okay, hoffentlich das alles im Bett. Das wollte ich nämlich auch nochmal fragen, weil grade diese Haftungsfreistellung für Hoster und äh Zugangsanbieter, die ist ja von sehr hohem Wert
und zwar in zweierlei Hinsicht. Einmal Wert für
Meinungsfreiheit und so weiter. Andererseits Wert für wirtschaftliche Freiheiten, die dadurch auch entstehen und ja vielfältig ausgenutzt werden.
Oder genutzt werden. Ähm.
Soll es da dran gehen? Steht das jetzt in Gefahr? Ähm oder also ist das etwas, wo wir jetzt schon alarmiert sein müssen oder ist das etwas, wo man sagt, okay um diese Sache muss man sich jetzt kümmern, welche welche Gefahren lauern. Ist,
meine Frage.
Also du stellst eine gute Frage. Ich sage mal so, ja, ähm prinzipiell du hast absolut recht, das jetzige Haftungsregime.
Ist essentiell für das Internet, wie wir's heute kennen. Ohne dem.
Wirst du sofort immer in der Haftung, wenn irgendwo was Illegales passiert, das heißt, du musst immer vom Schlimmsten ausgehen, bei allen deinen Usern.
Ähm wenn wir das nicht gehabt hätten, wäre das Internet nie so bunt, so innovativ, so divers geworden. Und das ist vielen Leuten auch in der Kommission bewusst, vielen Leuten in der Debatte bewusst.
Ob es nicht trotzdem irgendwelche ähm Leute gibt, die meinen, hey, wir müssen aber jetzt mit der Machete alles absägen,
Und eigentlich wollen wir wieder Kabelfernsehen haben. Ähm das weiß ich nicht. Also so wie man beim Urheberrecht zum Beispiel das Haftungsregime.
Kaputt gemacht hat, worunter jetzt ja gerade viele kleine Plattformen leiden, das hätte ich auch nie für möglich gehalten und das haben auch viele Leute.
Total gefährlich, äh kritisiert, gerade auch eben für die kleinen Plattformen. Ähm insofern traue ich mich nicht, hier komplett Entwarnung zu geben. Ich kann nur sagen, es ist fast allen in der Debatte bewusst, dass man das nicht will.
Ähm wenn irgendein Industrielobby ist, aber mit
Terry Beton, dem Digitalkommissar, so richtig äh sauber essen geht und ihnen das vielleicht als Idee verkauft, kann ich nicht ausschließen, dass das nicht doch irgendwann mal.
Aber es es ist im Moment auf jeden Fall.
Und dass man kleine Plattformen hier nicht überlassen will und dass es wichtig ist, dass man große Haftungsausnahmen hat, ähm.
Das ist schon eigentlich das, was was äh man von allen Leuten hört und.
Ähm es ist ganz lustig. Also jetzt zum Beispiel, wo es mehr um Fake News und nicht mehr um Urheberrecht geht. Wir hatten letztens einen,
Dialog bei Timo Wolken, als auch Europaabgeordneter der SPD und der hat auch jemand von der Urheberrechtsindustrie gesagt, also Uploadfilter für ähm ähm Fake News wären eine ganz schlechte Idee.
Ja, also die wollen auch dieses Instrument, der Upload-Filter, wofür sie ja noch im Urheberrecht geworben haben. Ihnen ist auch klar, dass das hier bei Meinungsdelikten super gefährlich wäre.
Also die Sensibilität ist ist höher bei diesem Pfeil ähm und ich hoffe, dass man so im im Konsens bleibt und äh die verrückten Wortmeldungen nicht zu laut werden.
Eine wichtige Frage noch, ist Axel Voss irgendwo in der Nähe? Okay, also also ist es gefährlich. Es ist ein Spiel mit dem Feuer.
Wir wissen noch nicht, zumindest ich weiß es noch nicht, wer, wer irgendwie im Gespräch ist für Berichterstatter und Shadow,
und auch an welche Partei da gehen wird, ist mir zumindest jetzt noch nicht bewusst
Ähm und dadurch ist es noch offen. Und das wäre natürlich der Supergau. Aber ich hoffe, dass äh der Voss äh die hier nicht ähm in die wichtigste Rolle des Europaparlaments gesetzt wird.
Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
So viel mal zum DSE. Das Thema wird uns eh noch beschäftigen und ähm ja, wir werden auf jeden Fall auch weiter wieder drüber berichten.
So, Polizei, Linus.
Wo auch die Hoffnung zuletzt gestorben ist, ist bei den G20 ähm Gewalt.
Auswucherern Auswucherungen ähm diese Sendung hatten wir hier ja immer mal wieder empfohlen.
Tim, du hattest da äh wir hatten sie verlinkt. Das war, man, die hat ja so einen schönen Titel. Ein wichtige Bitte oder wie war das?
Bitte.
Dringende Bitte, Logbuchnetzpolitik mit dem dringende Bitte, wo uns.
Wo wir uns ausführlich mit dem auseinandergesetzt haben, was in Hamburg.
Zum T zwanzig Gipfel passiert ist und da gibt es jetzt ein Update zum Thema.
Polizeigewalt, die da stattgefunden hat
Ähm bevor er sich jetzt wieder Leute melden und sagen, da hätte keine Polizeigewalt stattgefunden, da gibt es eine sehr ausführliche Dokumentation von
glaube ich, diese Webseite G20 minus Doku Punkt org, die also eine ganze Reihe an ähm.
Sehr zweifelsfreien ähm,
Gewaltanwendungen, unnötigen Gewaltanwendungen durch die Polizei dokumentiert hat und,
die diese diese Gewalt und Körperverletzungen, da die hatten natürlich auch Ermittlungen äh nach sich gezogen und es wurden einhundertneunundsechzig Verfahren.
Eingeleitet, hundertdreiunddreißig davon wegen Körperverletzung im Amt.
Ja? Ähm und das heißt, ne, wenn so ein Verfahren eingeleitet wird, dann heißt das schon, dass.
Gibt's jetzt auch einen ausreichenden äh Tatverdacht und Anfangsverdacht, dass so ein Verfahren auch wirklich äh angemessen ist.
Davon hat bislang kein einziges zu einer Anklage geführt, weil.
Teilweise die Täterinnen nicht identifiziert werden konnten, ne? Die Polizisten sind ja vermummt oder weil die Ermittlungsbehörden dann den Gewalteinsatz doch für gerechtfertigt,
hielten insgesamt sind also von diesen hundertneunundsechzig Verfahren, hundertdreiunddreißig wegen Körperverletzungen, hundert,
zwanzig eingestellt. In vierundzwanzig von diesen hunderteinundzwanzig
hundertzwanzig eingestellten Verfahren konnten die Leute nicht gefunden werden. Das heißt also, jedes fünfte Ermittlungsverfahren.
Wegen Körperverletzung.
Das eingestellt wurde, wurde einfach eingestellt, weil die Täter nicht festgestellt werden konnten. Und das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein.
Denke ich sehr spannendes Thema, weil zumindest hier in Berlin.
Ja eine Kennzeichnungspflicht besteht. Ähm da das war man, ich weiß nicht, seit wann, aber auf jeden Fall würde ich so schätzen, ungefähr seit zehn Jahren ist das in Berlin.
Dass die Polizisten im Dienst eine Kennzeichnung tragen, die können ein Namensschild anbringen, die können aber auch eine,
Nummer anbringen. Wichtig ist, dass man das nachher, wenn es irgendwelche Aufzeichnungen gibt, aber wenn man sich beschweren möchte, ähm.
Jemals bei so einem Polizisten im Einsatz nach dem Namen gefragt hat, wenn es jetzt dann mal irgendwie in eine brenzliche Situation kommt, weiß, wie gut der so einen Namensschit ist und wer jemals ein Gewaltvideo.
Äh fotografiert hat oder gefilmt hat, weiß auch, wie wichtig sowas etwas ist. Da wehren sich aber diese ganzen Polizeigewerkschaften und.
Die Konservativen immer gegen, weil das ja so ein Generalverdacht wäre. Das das finde ich sehr lustig, weil ich meine, die Polizei.
Agiert ja auf Generalverdacht, das ist ja auch vollkommen in Ordnung, dass sie einen Generalverdacht gegen die Bevölkerung hat, um dort irgendwie für für Ruhe zu sorgen.
Und ich denke, so eine Kennzeichnungspflicht insbesondere, ne, natürlich eine anonymisierte.
Beziehungsweise pseudonymisierte. Von mir aus können die auch jeden Tag ihre Nummer wechseln. So lange nachvollziehbar ist, wenn man sagt, an diesem Tag hat Nummer XY mir folgendes angetan, dass dann.
Zumindest die Möglichkeit besteht, so eine.
So ein Gewaltexzess zur Anwendung zu bringen. Und ich weiß, dass da jetzt regelmäßig irgendwelche Leute so ja, die Polizei macht auch nur ihren Job und so, ne? Ja, tun sie.
Und es sind auch nur Menschen und genau deswegen brauchen sie eben auch eine Kontrolle, ja? Und diese Kontrolle, wenn die unwirksam ist und ähm diese Gewalt, die sie anwenden können.
Ungesühnt bleibt, wenn sie ihre.
Macht Mittel missbrauchen, irgendwelche Menschen mit Pfefferspray zusprühen und so weiter und so fort. Leute treten, die aufm Boden liegen. Ähm,
muss da eine Kontrolle rein und da diese Kontrolle ist natürlich dann auch immer der Teil der ja Vertrauen schafft. Ich habe das,
insbesondere im Kontext dieser Corona-App immer gesagt, ne? Man kann nicht Vertrauen verlangen, wenn man nicht auch die Möglichkeit zur Kontrolle bietet. Das ist das,
was man tun kann und das sehen wir jetzt hier in dem Ergebnis zu dieser.
G20-Auswertung. Die Daten, die ich da grade zitiert habe, sind äh aus einer
äh großen Anfrage der linken Fraktion in Hamburg und wurden auch auf Netzpolitik org nochmal von Markus Reuter kommentiert, der ja bei uns auch zum G20 Thema in der Sendung war.
Übrigens eine der meistgeladenen und wahrscheinlich auch gehörten Sendungen, die wir hier bisher gemacht haben.
Es ist super relevant, weil verhandele in Österreich gerade eine Meldestelle für Polizei, Gewalt,
Wir fordern in diesem Zuge auch Kennzeichnungspflicht und das ist gerade ein super Beispiel dafür, dass so das eine nicht ohne das andere haben kannst. Also eine Meldestelle vom Polizeigewalt, wo du nachher nicht genau sagen kannst, wer's war,
ist einfach komplett nutzlos.
Ja, aber dass das die erfolgreichste Folge war, Tim, ne? Ich meine, weiß true crime zieht immer, ne? Und.
Halt massenhafte Körperverletzung im Amt, ne.
Ja gut, aber die meist äh es gilt dann auch so zwei Sendungen, die waren noch häufiger geladen. Äh die eine heißt das Internet setzt sich endlich durch und äh das andere ist was mit Glasfaseranschluss. Also ich glaube, das zieht noch mehr. Wenn die Leute so die Hoffnung kriegen, Internet zu bekommen.
Vielleicht sollten wir das bei der Betitung dieser Folge berücksichtigen.
Mehr Internet, mehr.
Ach ja, System Hoffnung.
Thomas, dein dein erster Erfolg war doch diese Netzneutralitätsgeschichte. Du hast da gerade schon drauf äh Bezug genommen. Wie ist denn da eigentlich im Moment der Stand auf EU-Ebene?
Ja, ich äh muss hier einfach nur berichten. Es gibt eine ähm eine Reform der europäischen Netzautralität
die gerade abgeschlossen ist, ähm also jetzt ähm im Juni vor vor ein paar Wochen. Wir haben ja heute den ersten Juli. Ähm,
ist äh diese Reform, die eineinhalb Jahre lang ähm gedauert hat, endlich abgeschlossen und das sind ein paar spannende Neuerungen drinnen für uns. Ähm wir erinnern uns ähm.
Die Uhr hat ja seit zweitausendsechzehn Netznetralität und ähm es gibt äh von, also von dem Zusammenschluss der Telekom-Regulierungsbehörden immer so Guidelines, die diese Gesetze auslegen. Und ähm.
Das Ganze ähm war ein ein heftiges Gezerre zwischen den Regulierungsbehörden und äh vielen anderen Stakeholdern. Ähm und eines der Themen, die da am heftigsten diskutiert wurde, war 5G
Ähm fünf G, der neue Mobilfunk äh Standard, ähm der nicht für Corona verantwortlich ist. Ähm,
der nicht für Corona verantwortlich ist. Ähm da gibt es andere Aspekte, die einem Sorgen machen können, nämlich sogenannte Network-Slices.
Also 5G erlaubte mir, dass ich ähm ein Mobilfunknetz bekomme, das äh besonders Bandbreiten optimiert ist oder niedrige Latenz hat oder eben,
besonders weniger Energieverbrauch. Also durchaus Sachen, die man haben will, dadurch stellt sich so die Frage, wer entscheidet denn jetzt, welche App, auf welches Networks kommt? Also kriegt Netflix äh die hohe Bandbreite oder kriegt die nur YouTube.
Und ähm
Das ist eine Frage, die das Netz von Netznetralitätsperspektive bisher noch nicht beantwortet war, obwohl die EU hier das erste Mal versucht hat, äh ein regulatorisches Regime aufzustellen. Und ähm wir haben's geschafft
dass wir uns mit unserer ursprünglichen Position hier durchsetzen, nämlich dass es wirklich komplett dem User überlassen sein soll wir dieser Netzwerkslice nutzt,
Also es muss wirklich auf dem Endgerät in der Kontrolle des sein,
einstellt, na, ich will aber ähm jetzt auf das Low Energy Slice mit allen meinen Apps, außer dieser einen vielleicht, ähm oder ich will äh für dieses Spiel jetzt irgendwie die niedrige Latenz haben. Ähm das soll wirklich auf den Endgeräten
passieren und da haben die Telekom-Betreiber und auch die App Anbieter nichts mitzureden dabei. Ähm.
Das ist super wichtig, weil ähm damit auch die Geschäftsmodelle, die mit 5G äh gebaut werden, welche sein werden, die uns in die Kontrolle versetzen, selber zu entscheiden.
Und äh dass es da eben keine Abmachungen, ist ein äh großen Telekombetreibern wie der deutschen Telekom und großen Inhaltsanbietern mit äh fetten Taschen wie Netflix geben kann, dass man irgendjemanden einer Priorität gibt.
Ähm sind wir super happy drüber und haben das auch entsprechend gefeiert.
Ähm eine andere wirklich tolle Sache, die wir durchbekommen haben, äh war, dass sich nichts verändert. Und zwar im Thema die Inspection.
Ich weiß nicht, ob
Inspection hier schon mal erklärt wurde. Ähm das ist eine Technik, bei der ein Telekom-Betreiber besonders tief in die Pakete hineinschaut. Also ähm
wirklich auch die Inhalte bewertet, sprich die äh URLs, die du aufrufst, die,
ähm äh die Domains, die du ansurfst, vielleicht sogar die Texte, die auf den Websites sind, äh die du dir anschaust, wenn das unverschlüsselt ist, all das kann man unter die Inspection,
verstehen und es gab
Bestrebungen, gerade auch von der Bundesnetzagentur, dass man die erlauben will. Im Moment verbietet die Netzzentralität das.
Und da haben wir es geschafft, die ähm Linie zu halten, die PI bleibt verbo.
Alles, was unter LEA vier dem Transport leer ist, das Internet ist ja schichtbasiert, darf weiter nicht angegriffen werden oder angeschaut werden von Internetprovidern.
Gerade bei dem Thema hatten wir auch Schützenhilfe ähm von dem European Data Protection Board. Also wir haben da,
offenen Brief auch äh die Datenschutzcommunity mobilisiert und das hat sich bezahlt gemacht äh bei den zwei Themen haben wir auf ähm ganzer Linie gewonnen.
Dann gab's noch eine ein ein neues Thema Jugendschutzfilter wurden diskutiert,
Also das freiwillige Sperren von einzelnen Teilen des Internets, dass du bei deinem ISB sagen kannst, ich hätte gerne.
Inhalte blockiert oder äh Spielseiten blockiert
ähm und sozusagen nachdem der User das wirklich explizit gefordert hat, dass das äh möglich sein soll oder nicht. Dafür gab's bisher noch keine Regeln und eigentlich sagt die Netzzentralitätsverordnung auch ganz klar, dass man,
den Geschäftsbedingungen eines Internetzugangsprodukts nicht die ähm Diskriminierungsregeln umgehen darf. Und dieser Grundsatz wurde auch beibehalten,
es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, dass man zum dass man DNS-Sperren macht, auch nichts, was darüber hinausgeht, dass er wirklich nur DNS sperren, aber die müssen halt immer ein zusätzliches Produkt sein, das sich extra erst buche,
und die dürfen den Gesamtpreis des Internets nicht billiger machen,
Ähm sie können neutral sein oder was kosten, aber ich kann sozusagen nicht das Jugendschutz, Internet per die Folgt on haben und wenn ich's wegmachen will, kostet es fünf Euro mehr.
Verhindert worden mit der Reform und finde ich auch eine ganz sinnvolle Lösung für das Thema. Ähm,
dann bei ähm die die einzige wirklich andere große Sache war eigentlich bei Zero-Rating. Ähm also bei dem,
Diskriminieren zwischen Anwendungen über den Preis
dass zum Beispiel ähm wie's in Portugal der Fall ist. YouTube fünfzig Mal billiger ist als jedes Gigabyte, was ich sonst irgendwie kaufen kann. Ähm das äh sogenannte Serorating oder Defensur Pricing ähm ist etwas, das wir.
Ähm gerne stärker eingeschränkt hätten. Äh da haben wir uns nicht durchgesetzt, also es gibt keine roten Linien, welche Arten von Seurating,
nicht OK sind, aber bei den Arten von die OK sind gibt's
äh durchaus äh positive Entwicklungen. Ähm und da hat man auch Sprache von uns, aus vorherigen Einreichungen direkt übernommen, in die Guidelines, dass es jetzt eben äh sowas wie Stream on,
werden wir wahrscheinlich in Europa öfter sehen, also diese klassenbasierten Systeme, wo du die Kategorie Musik oder die Kategorie Video oder die Kategorie Gaming hast und ähm,
Anbieter von äh Apps in diesem Bereich können sich dann bei dem melden und ihren Dienst dort auch in mit hineinbringen. Ähm als
Netzzentralitätsbefürworter bin ich immer noch gegen so ein Modell, aber es,
ist es trotzdem nicht ganz so schlimm, wie die klassischen, hier hast du halt WhatsApp gratis Angebote. Und ähm ja
es ist man merkt, dass es dann an ES gibt oder dass die die die Regulierungsbehörden wissen, dass das so eine Flanke ist, die sie offen haben und sie wollen da etwas tun, sie wollen auch etwas gegen.
Dieser Silobildung machen. Es ist ja vor allem im europäischen Binnenmarkt schwierig, wenn du nur noch Angebote von großen amerikanischen Anbietern hast. Ähm
aber es ist halt auch ein Thema, wo sie sich nicht getraut haben, wirklich unseren Empfehlungen zu folgen und stärker einzuschränken. Und
Sonst gab's nur ein paar Verschlechterungen bei der Transparenzbestimmungen. Also eigentlich sollte in Internetverträgen ja drinnen stehen, welche Geschwindigkeiten man hat, welches Verkehrsmanagement man hat, ob's irgendwelche Einflüsse auf den Datenschutz,
durch Verkehrsmanagement und ähm ja,
diese Bestimmungen wurden sogar noch verschlechtert. Ähm das ist ziemlich schade, weil Transparenz äh ja immer gut ist, gerade bei äh auf der Konsumentinnenebene.
Ähm ja und das das ist so grob, was wir bei dieser Reform jetzt durchbekommen haben.
Jetzt hast du gerade Netznetralität angesprochen und zero-Rating. Und äh das erinnert mich, dass wir hier in äh Lokbuch Netzpolitik,
und auch in.
Anderen Presseinterviews und so ein bisschen mit dem Thema äh Corona-Warnapp-Traffic ist auseinandergesetzt haben. Und da,
Das war immer so ein Thema, wo ich gesagt habe, ja, da halte ich mich jetzt mal kurz äh Netzneutralität ist wichtig und äh die Zero-Rating ist problematisch, aber das halten wir jetzt mal kurz außen vor, weil die Sorge der Leute ist ja, dass Jakob alle geht oder ihr Datenvolumen
und diese Sorge kann man den Leuten nehmen. Ähm wie siehst du denn das mit dem Zero-Rating bei so Corona-Apps?
Also ähm da geht's mir ähnlich wie dir, es ist was, dass ich ähm unschön finde ähm,
äh ich ich würde mir eine Welt wünschen, wo alle eine Flatrate haben, ähm so wie in Finnland
und du hast halt unterschiedliche Geschwindigkeiten. Ähm das wäre auch das ehrlichere Geschäftsmodell, weil Datenvolumen kostet eigentlich nichts
in so einer Welt hätten wir dieses Problem gar nicht. Nun leben wir in der Welt, die wir haben und Telkos wollen Geld verdienen und deswegen verkaufen sie uns Daten. Und nicht nur Zugang.
Ähm aber auch wenn du in so einer Welt lebst und solche Internetprodukte zu Haufen am Markt hast, gebe es äh bessere Lösungen, dass du sagst, es gibt ähm.
Zum Beispiel alles, was einer Punkt Goff Domain hat oder was wirklich aus dem Gesundheitsbereich kommt. Es gibt so neutrale Kriterien, die du technisch auch erkennen kannst,
Aber es ist nicht so, dass die Deutsche Telekom entscheidet, ach, wir sind jetzt hier mal großzügig und wir schenken euch dieses Datenvolumen, was uns eigentlich eh nichts kostet, ähm sondern ich hätte gerne, dass es neutrale technische Kriterien gibt und dass ich nicht zu
Telekombetreiber als Bittsteller gehen muss und auf dessen Kooperation hoffen, ähm sondern, dass es ein
System ist, ähm dass auch äh weltweit funktioniert, wo ich dann auch wenn ich in einem anderen EU-Land zu Hause bin, vielleicht dann das,
bekomme, wenn ich äh die deutsche App hier verwende. Oder auch andere,
Gesundheitsdienstleister, jetzt bei der Stop-Corona-App haben wir staatliche Monopole, es gibt immer nur eine App für ein Land, aber bei vielen anderen Gesundheitsanwendungen, die man vielleicht auch, äh
unabhängig von äh der Größe Ihres Internetvertrags zu äh,
gestehen will, wär's doch schön, wenn wir einfach so einen Standard hätten, dass es Kategorie Gesundheit und wo das ist, fällt es überall hinein.
Oder Katastrophenschutz oder sowas.
Also ich ich hätte da gerne ein System, wo die Telkos nicht die Gate-Keeper sind, sondern wo wir uns auf äh neutrale technische Standards einigen, die ähm.
Oder das Zuordnen zu Kategorien von Zero-Rating-Regeln.
Hörst wirklich ein kniffliger Punkt, ne, grade was du jetzt eben noch mal gesagt hast, bist du ja eigentlich schöner, wenn man wenn man sozusagen nur eine Geschwindigkeit kauft.
Das kann natürlich dann mit so einer äh App auch ein Problem werden, ne? Weil wenn da irgendwie viel Daten ausgetauscht werden müssen und dann dauert das auch noch lange. Hm, na ja, egal. Also da steckt der Teufel wirklich im,
Detail. Ähm diese Neutralitätsreform, also ab wann ist die äh.
In Kraft, also gilt das jetzt im Prinzip schon oder ist das jetzt nur eine Anpassung, der ist existierenden Gesetzes und das ist jetzt so, gilt sofort oder.
Ach ähm, wie hat's mal in so einer äh wichtigen deutschen Pressekonferenz geheißen? Nach meinem Kenntnisstand gilt es ab sofort. Also die Regeln sind.
Verzüglich sozusagen. Mhm.
Genau. Also die sind mit äh Juni jetzt äh von von äh dem äh beschlossen worden und sind auch schon in Kraft. Die sind auch äh mehr oder weniger der Beipackzettel für das Gesetz, den die Regulierungsbehörden
verwenden in der Auslegung dieses Gesetzes. Und ähm insofern ähm jetzt bei
alles, was jetzt in dem laufenden Jahr und im nächsten Halbjahr passiert, werden wir dann auch in den,
der Regulierungsbehörden lesen können, wie sie diese Regeln umgesetzt haben. Was ich als nächstes bei Netzzentralität tun wird, ist, dass wir ein Gerichtsverfahren haben, ähm aus Ungarn
betrifft
das wird sehr spannend, weil da geht's wirklich so um die Kernfrage, ob die Lesart der Regulierungsbehörden bei überhaupt äh die richtige ist. Äh wenn wir das gewinnen, dann könnte das sehr gut für die Netzzentralität sein.
Das Gegenteil ist leider auch eine Möglichkeit. Ähm und auf Gesetzgeberischer Ebene glaube ich nicht, dass sich irgendjemand traut äh Netzzentralität die nächsten
vier, fünf Jahre anzugreifen. Also das wird äh alles mal so bleiben, wie es ist. Unter dem Regime, was wir jetzt grade reformiert haben und ähm.
Eigentlich geht's jetzt eher so um andere ähm Weltteile, wo man sich um Netzzentralität mehr Sorgen machen muss. Also ähm
schon genannte Markus Reuter ist, glaube ich, ja noch äh verweilt nicht in Europa und was der mir teilweise so für für Angebote von anderen Weltregionen schickt
Also wir sind gerade eher so in dem Thema am global herumstochern, weil in Europa tut sich jetzt einfach gerade nicht so viel.
Okay. Schön. Womit machen wir weiter? Mit.
Mit Lügen, Lügen auf Facebook. Was ganz Neues. Ähm.
Also, es gab ja jetzt eine äh Debatte, die wir hier in, im Lokbuch, glaube ich, gar nicht so weit hervorgekehrt haben.
Was wir behandelt haben ist.
Dass Twitter vor einigen Wochen damit begonnen hat, Beiträge von Trump mit Hinweisen zu versehen.
Wenn diese nicht den Fakten entsprechen. Twitter hat sich dabei äh
würde ich sagen schon erstmal relativ wenig elegant angestellt, ne? Es war dann irgendwie Thema Briefwahl und so weiter, wo sie dann gesagt haben, hier klicke hier, wenn du irgendwie die Wahrheit äh über die Briefwahl erfahren möchtest oder so, ne? Ähm.
Sie haben ja dann auch diese Hinweise gemacht, okay, dieser hier, dieser,
des Präsidenten verletzt die Standards, die wir die Minimalstandards an das Zusammenleben, die wir auf dieser Plattform an unsere Nutzerinnen stellen und bei Facebook war da irgendwie überhaupt nichts zu sehen, ne? Äh,
Facebook hat sich in der Hinsicht keiner Richtung bewegt und auch keine Anstalten unternommen.
Und das führte zu einem Anzeigenboykott, wo eine Reihe an Unternehmen gesagt haben, pass mal auf, wenn eure Community irgendwie so weitergeht mit so einem,
mit diesen Hassbotschaften, mit dem mit der wenigen.
Was da an äh was da bei euch abgeht, dann werden wir einfach keine Anzeigen mehr bei euch schalten.
Und jetzt hat Facebook in schneller Folge erstmal angekündigt, okay, künftig.
Beiträge von Politikern zu markieren, wenn sie irgendwie gegen die Rundnutzungsregeln verstoßen. Das gilt auch für Trump. Also durch starken Druck hat Facebook jetzt tatsächlich gesagt, okay, wir.
Ähm werden auch Trump korrigieren oder markieren, wenn er hier unsere Regeln nicht einhält.
Also, den starken Druck, den gab's schon die ganze Zeit. Das Wein bloß scheißegal, aber jetzt haben die gesagt, ja, dann gibt's aber keine Kohle mehr. Und dann so, oh, nee, nee, war er nicht so gemeint, irgendwie machen.
Das meinte ich mit starkem Druck.
Mhm. Überzeugende Argumente könnte man auch sagen.
Das ist tatsächlich, ne, also ähm,
Zuckerberg hat er ja auch sehr wenig Zweifel dran gelassen, dass er über das Thema überhaupt noch nachdenken würde, ne? Also hier sieht man tatsächlich, das ist dieser finanzielle Druck, diese Anzeigen-Boykott-Kampagne, die diese Wirkung hatte.
Und sie haben außerdem.
Jetzt heute, glaube ich, ähm mehrere, eine ganze Reihe an Accounts von so Anhängern und gelöscht.
Anhänger, das sind diese Typen, die in Hawaii Hemden irgendwie bei den Krawallen auftauchen,
und irgendwie eine mir nicht ganz klare ähm noch nicht ganz klaren Hintergrund haben, die irgendwie meinen, dass,
im Prinzip der Frieden jetzt nur noch durch einen Bürgerkrieg herzustellen sei und ähm deswegen zu Gewalt Exzessen,
bei Demonstrationen neigen und ähm ja, also.
Oder auch bei den Black Live Matter Demos äh aufgetaucht sind und
angestiftet haben oder sozusagen überhaupt Gewalt erst ausgelöst haben, obwohl sie im Prinzip genau das Gegenteil damit bewegt haben. Also sie wollten sozusagen, dass es den Demonstranten dann in die Schuhe geschoben wird, um eben dieses Narrativ zu bedienen mit der, dass der hier alles
äh gewalttätige Protest laden, die müssen mal ordentlich weggefegt werden und
da ist so diese Bungalow-Bewegung, eine von mehreren merkwürdigen Bewegungen in USA, die sich da breit macht und in letzter Zeit einfach sehr unangenehm auffällt und ja, die haben's jetzt mal abbekommen. Aber gibt auch noch genug andere.
Genau, also Teile von denen wurden also jetzt mal,
medienwirksam von Facebook geschmissen, also ein paar hundert Konten, äh dreihundertzwanzig Konten, hundert Gruppen, achtundzwanzig Seiten dieses rechtsextremen Netzwerks wurden gesperrt und,
Twitch hat Trumps Kampagnen-Account gesperrt, was auch.
Der hatte jetzt nicht so viele Subscriber, aber man merkt einfach,
da da bewegt sich jetzt was. Der Druck wird einfach äh von den Leuten ausgelöst oder hat sicherlich jetzt diese ganze Protestwelle um Black Live Schmetter nochmal eine ganze Menge äh zusätzliche Energie freigesetzt, aber es ist natürlich vor allem
diese bevorstehende Wahl,
Ja, das hat ja die USA nun auch schon einmal alles durch und alle, die so halbwegs klar denken, wissen genau, was jetzt kommt, insbesondere in der Situation, dass äh die Traum-Administration derzeit einfach mal richtig scheiße da steht
und dass das natürlich genau eine noch,
Ein noch krasseres Kommunikationsverhalten nach sich ziehen wird, dass da kann man einfach mal
mit rechnen und deswegen ist es ganz sinnvoll jetzt diesen Druck auch zu erhöhen, dass das eben nicht einfach wieder so ein vollkommen unkontrolliertes Spiel der Kräfte ist.
Und grade bei Twitch frage ich mich halt auch, ob es nicht äh so ein bissel auch ein Schillen auf die Umfragen ist, ähm weil in den USA gibt's vor allem bei den Demokraten auch die Debatte, ob man nicht
Plattformregulierung machen will und die wissen auch, wenn sie ihn jetzt äh weiter komplett ungehindert
auf ihren Plattformen lassen dann dann steigt der Regulierungsapetit noch mehr.
Einfach mal Kandidaten, der jetzt in Umfragen eh immer mehr abstürzt,
gänzlich unmoderiert zu lassen und die eigenen AGBs nicht zu entforschen, dass es auch eine Kostennutzenkalkulation.
Guter Punkt.
Also ich bin da noch nicht so weit. Also es sieht gerade wirklich so aus, als wäre dieser Trump jetzt mal endlich erledigt, ja? Aber das äh habe ich
vor vier Jahren zu dieser Zeit des Jahres auch gedacht, dass der die Wahl nicht gewinnen würde, insofern würde ich das jetzt, würde ich da die Hoffnung mal noch gedämpft lassen
was natürlich,
durchaus auch eine Rolle spielt, ist diese gesamte russian Madling Nummer, die halt dann auch noch jahrelang in den USA diskutiert wurde und die müssen sich natürlich jetzt auch.
Sozialen Netzwerke sehr warm anziehen.
Einfach in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass da jetzt ein Wahlkampf des Weges daherkommt, in dem wieder eine ganze Reihe an komischen Phänomenen,
stattfinden wird, in der sie mit allerlei konzertierten Aktionen in ihren Netzwerken konfrontiert werden und dann,
unter Umständen nachher heißt das waren staatliche Akteur oder irgendein Cambridge Analytica oder irgendetwas. Insofern kann ich das gut verstehen, dass sie da jetzt sagen, nee komm, nochmal begeben wir uns in die
Positionen nicht.
Ja, wird ein spannender Wahlkampf.
Ähm gut, dann sag doch mal Thomas, eure Corona-App. Habt ihr inzwischen die Deutsche geklohnt oder wie ist eure Strategie?
Ja ich äh wünschte mir, wir hätten ähm also wir haben jetzt in Österreich auch ähm eine eine App auf dem.
Die zentralen Google-Apple Framework und ich fand, es ist ein guter Zeitpunkt nochmal zu kontrastieren, wie Österreich, Deutschland jetzt so dastehen, also
kurz zur Chronologie, wir haben ja eh hier im Podcast schon mal drüber geredet, dass Österreich sehr früh ähm schon Anfang März mit der konkreten Entwicklung einer App begonnen hat, da natürlich, wie zu erwarten, in die Restriktionen äh von von,
Geräten äh hineingelaufen ist, die im Hintergrund kein Bluetooth erlauben und ähm man hat dann eine App gemacht, die immer noch
ähm gut gemeint, aber ein bisschen schlecht gemacht war. Wir haben das Ganze reviewt, auch gemeinsam mit ähm,
Mark Schreiben seiner NGO und und SBA Research und ähm Teil der Empfehlungen, wer auch nur, also wir haben da sechsundzwanzig Empfehlungen rausgegeben und Teil von dem, was wir sozusagen ähm als Missstand identifiziert haben
wurde jetzt dann eben auch mit der Architekturwechsel,
auf das sezentrale Framework äh behoben. Also wir sind noch im Review des neuen Kurdes, aber es sieht zumindest danach aus, dass die mehr oder weniger alles richtig gemacht haben und die äh App auch keine gravierenden Datenschutzmängel hat.
Ähm und äh die App funktioniert,
ein bisschen anders als die in Deutschland, glaube ich, weil sie hat äh auch die Möglichkeit, eine Symptombasierte Meldung zu machen, also nicht nur nach einer erfolgten Lastung.
Ähm und man kann auch Meldungen zurücknehmen. Ähm das Ganze funktioniert rein über eine Autoisierung mittels Handynummer,
also die Anbindung, wie sie in Deutschland zumindest, glaube ich, gedacht ist, dass die Labor sozusagen wirklich kurz rausgeben, ähm es ist äh hier keine Option, einfach was die Infrastruktur in den Labors nicht gibt.
Die haben wir in Deutschland doch auch nicht.
Aber ich ich dachte, dass das geplant ist oder ist da nicht die Deutsche Telekom beteiligt.
Ist geplant. Es dauert eine Weile.
Wir wir haben.
Wo war ich genau? Was noch ganz spannend ist, ja, also diese Symptombasierte Meldung kann man sich so vorstellen, man ruft bei der Hotline an äh und sagt dazu irgendwie ja, ich habe Husten
und ähm,
also es ist sehr niederschwellig. Ich glaube äh bin gar nicht sicher, ob es nicht nur ein Formular bei der App ist, dass dann über einen SMS-Truppen funktioniert,
Es ist auf jeden Fall sehr leicht möglich, so eine Symptombasierte Meldung abzugeben und äh trotzdem gab es bisher noch keine Fälle von Missbrauch bei der bei der App,
Ähm aber was ich signifikant finde, sind die Download-Zeilen.
Also äh wir reden von siebenhundertfünfzehntausend ähm Mal, die die App wirklich runtergeladen wurde und scheinbar gibt es da aber auch eine recht hohe sechsstellige Zahl von Die Installationen
Ähm das heißt, die Verbreitung der Stopp-Corona-App ist in Österreich um einiges geringer als in Deutschland.
Und ich glaube auch zu wissen, wieso das so ist, weil ähm bei uns die Debatte halt einfach.
Zeitpunkt war, ähm wo wirklich noch die äh der Lockdown,
ganz massiv, weil die Leute auch noch äh viel verängstigter waren, teilweise auch ähm in dem Gesamtklima ähm die Politik hat bei uns auch ja den Leiten sehr stark ins Gewissen geredet, von wegen,
Herausforderung seit dem zweiten Weltkrieg. Und ähm da war einfach auch sehr viel Misstrauen dieser Lockdown-Situation da und ähm.
Die Politik hat da nicht äh vertrauensbildend mitgewirkt, sondern es gab äh vor allem von den Konservativen immer wieder mal äh diese laut geäußerte Idee, man könnte die App äh ja verpflichtend machen, ähm,
was aus den vorher eh schon in Feedback genannten.
Datenschutzgründen gar nicht möglich wäre, ähm aber trotzdem hat man das immer wieder als Option in den Raum gestellt und da ist viel Vertrauen zerstört worden und inzwischen ist es auch so, dass die Opposition
ganz knallhart gegen die App schießt und der überhaupt nicht vertrauen will,
Ähm und äh da ist einfach sehr viel Vertrauen zerstört worden, sodass es jetzt auf jeden Fall in Österreich schwierig ist, auch wenn die App technisch gesehen, aus Datenschutzperspektive nicht schlecht ist.
Dass man überhaupt mal sie wieder in das Licht rückt, wo Menschen bereitwilligt, das Ding sich auch installieren und dann auch korrekt verwenden wollen. Ähm also.
Dass das ist so grob, wo wir da in Österreich stehen. Das ist keine sonderlich gute Situation, aber ich fand's irgendwie mal wichtig, auch so als Feedback.
Wie 'ne Debatte verlaufen kann, wenn sie einfach nur ein bisschen früher passiert so Querschüsse wie Sarah Waggenich könnte ich auch in Österreich Beispiele nennen sowohl von FPÖ wie auch Sozialdemokratie,
aber ähm ja, wir versuchen jetzt halt auch vielleicht über ein Gesetz, das die Freiwilligkeit absichert, eine Forderung durchzubringen und mehr Vertrauen zu schaffen,
aber ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob diese Zahlen noch in einem Bereich kommen, wo die App wirklich ein signifikanten Beitrag zur Bekämpfung der Pandemie leisten kann, so dass epidologisch überhaupt.
Der Fall ist.
Ich habe mal kurz nachgerechnet, mir mal die Bevölkerungszahlen angeschaut, also siebenhundertfünfzehntausend äh Downloads entsprechen ungefähr neun Komma fünf Prozent der Bevölkerung ab fünfzehn Jahren in Österreich. Da sind wir ja in Deutschland schon fast bei zwanzig Prozent. Wie gesagt
Downloads ähm auch in Deutschland fehlt ja derzeit die Möglichkeit, mal wirklich direkt zu erfahren, wie viel aktive
ist denn nun tatsächlich gibt, weil Download heißt ja erstmal noch gar nichts, das ist ja dann unter Umständen noch nicht mal gestartet worden. Es gibt ja auch diese ganzen Probleme mit äh Unternehmen, die das über ihre Firmenhandys, die App
äh über so einen Enterprise Distribution einfach mal installieren lassen, was dann unter Umständen auch noch als Download zählt, aber eben nicht wirklich als laufende App
und von daher ist es eh eine schwierige Zahl, weil man eben auch so Deinstallationen nicht mitbekommt.
Trotzdem ist natürlich das jetzt auch für dann für Österreich, für den längeren Zeitraum, wo die App ja schon verfügbar ist, doch relativ wenig.
Also ich glaube, was noch spannend ist in beiden Ländern, wird der Vergleich der Werbekampagnen, die sind ja, glaube ich, in beiden Ländern geplant. Ähm.
Ist übrigens meines Wissens noch so die erste sinnvolle Verwendung von Regierungsinseraten. Ähm wenn man die Latte darüber aufklärt.
Aber ähm ja, die Zahlen wird man vergleichen müssen und äh wenn man äh macht
ist es ja auch möglich, Statistiken zu erheben oder dieses von vorneherein anonymisiert oder über difency ähm unkritisch zu erheben.
Also da bin ich gespannt.
Nochmal interessant zu sehen, wie das dann eben äh auch sich mit den anderen europäischen Apps kombinieren lässt. Es wird ja gerade darüber diskutiert, diesen Schlüsselaus,
zu machen, aber das würde dann wirklich nur dann funktionieren, wenn äh die österreichische App halt nur die Keys weitergibt oder das Backend nur die Keys weitergibt, wo es jetzt auch wirklich einen bestätigten Test gibt
Ich habe das nicht so ganz verstanden, wie du das erklärt hast. Also.
Okay, es gibt die Möglichkeit, einfach nur zu sagen, so so ich warne so ein bisschen, so wie ich fühle mich nicht so gut. Ähm.
Aber wie läuft denn jetzt die Bestätigung mit dem Test, also wenn ich jetzt einen richtigen Test gemacht habe.
Auch der ist nur ähm über Telefonnummer. Also ich glaube, dass das äh.
Was heißt denn das über Telefonnummer?
Also ich habe den Prozess noch nicht gemacht, aber ich glaube, das ist ein eine SMS verification ist. Du gibst da eine Nummer ein und dann kriegst du einen äh SMS-Drucken, den du eingibst und ähm das tust du sowohl in dem,
gelben Fall des symptombasierten Meldungen wie auch in dem roten Fall, wenn du eine ein Laborergebnis hast.
Und äh das ist eben überhaupt nicht dran geknüpft, dass das Labor bestätigt, ja.
Dieses Telefon war jetzt gerade wirklich hier oder diese Person, zu der das Telefon hoffentlich gehört, war hier und hat eine Corona-Positiv-Testergebnis von mir bekommen.
Also man kann dafür ja argumentieren, ne, wenn man wenn man sagt ähm Test dauert viel zu lange und so weiter und so fort, zu sagen, okay zu diesen Zeiten des Jahres, wenn da jetzt auf einmal jemand
Symptome klagt mitten im im Hochsommer so ungefähr, dass man dann sagt, okay, komm
kannst jetzt auch äh eine Warnung auslösen und die ist dann eben gelb, ja? Wenn.
Aufgabe mit dieser App ist eine Schnelligkeit in der Meldung zu verfolgen, dann ist so etwas ja sinnvoll. Und wenn das von den.
Auch unterschiedlich.
Ausgewertet oder interpretiert oder bewertet wird, dass man sagt, okay, das war jetzt hier eine Warnung einer eine nicht verifizierte Warnung einer Person, die sich gerade schlecht fühlt, dann achte ich mal drauf, ob ich mich vielleicht auch schlecht fühle.
Klingt doch sinnvoll, vorausgesetzt, dass alle fair mitspielen.
Ja, also ich ich glaube auch, äh also,
ich find's ehrlich gesagt auch spannend, dass wir jetzt nicht nur die eine europäische App haben oder weltweite App haben, sondern dass es hier unterschiedliche Ansätze gibt
und dass das äh Google, Apple Frame wirkt das auch zulässt, weil ähm ich hätte gerne mehr Daten und einfach auch Fällstudien über die Verwendung dieser Apps, um,
sich dem Problem anzunähern. Das ist ja alles nicht trivial.
Und diese Sache mit der Symptombasierten Meldung kenne ich auch nur aus Österreich bisher, ich glaub wir haben uns hier das ausgedacht und das Rote Kreuz in Österreich scheint das eben auch bei Google, Apple ausreichend gut begründet,
zu haben, so dass das äh möglich war, dass ich nicht auch umzusetzen in dem Framework. Ähm also ich glaube, das ist technisch die Risikoklasse eines Tech ist, die da verwendet wird,
Spannend ist auch noch, dass die Gelbmeldung äh nur kürzer
im System bleibt, also sieben Tage. Man geht davon aus, dass zu dem Zeitpunkt dann ähm spätestens ein Labortest vorliegt und du ihn dann bei der Grünmeldung ähm also sprich negativer Test den Schlüssel einfach entfernst und bei einer
positiv Meldung einfach das hochsetzt auf eine rote wirklich bestätigte Meldung. Das ist so die.
Was was äh derzeit die Funktionslage davon ist.
Was denkst du denn jetzt also was sind mir nicht so ganz klar geworden ist,
wo ist denn jetzt so primär die Zurückhaltung begründet in Österreich, deiner Auffassung nach?
Dass das jetzt nicht so einschlägt. Also ist das jetzt einfach nur zu sehr zerredet worden oder
gibt's klare Anzeichen und, und, und, und öffentlichen Widerspruch, die sagen, die App wäre ja jetzt doch irgendwie noch viel zu gefährlich. Also, was ist so das.
Eigentliche Probleme.
Also das, was ich höre, ist so irgendwie, da ist ein Überwachungsmodul der Regierung drinnen und äh ich vertraue der App einfach nicht, äh ich will meine Daten dort nicht haben.
So wie bei uns auch ein.
Also es sind ähm es ist jetzt nicht irgendein neues substantiertes Argument, äh dass man da,
das ins Feld geführt wird. Man kann natürlich skeptisch sein, ob das Ding überhaupt sinnvoll ist, ähm und man konnte damals, man kann auch skeptisch sein, dass das Ding in Österreich von einer privaten Krankenkasse ursprünglich finanziert wurde von entwickelt und,
viele Fehler gemacht, wo wo man, glaube ich, auch in Deutschland ähm von vorneherein sich schon der Brisanz des Themas bewusst war, wegen dem Ganzen,
Ich glaube, Deutschland war ja viel näher dran bei dem Ganzen. Äh Papity und die Konflikt.
Und und hatte schon genügend Zickenkrieg um um zu wissen dass das mit der Kneifzange ein Projekt ist das wirklich transparent und so weiter gehandhabt werden muss. In Österreich hat man einfach mal gemacht.
Und ähm da ist halt eben so die Frage, dass das ähm,
welche Probleme die Leute immer noch mal gehört haben und immer noch äh glauben, dass das der Fall ist, auch in der alten Version gab's ja auch wirklich äh Fehler, die wir gefunden haben und dann als Empfehlung äh mitgegeben und.
Auch dass das jetzt zum Teil behoben ist, ist was wo ähm,
die Leiter nicht wirklich genau mitverfolgen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie man das wieder gedreht bekommt. Und ob ob überhaupt eine Werbekampagne dann der richtige Weg dafür ist.
Eigentlich? Nee, ne?
Wir verlinken auch das Gitterri. Also ist komplett offen.
Und ich glaube aber auch so eben der europäische Vergleich wird wichtig sein und ähm was die Interoperabilität betrifft. Ich glaube, es fehlen jetzt ja eh nur noch Großbritannien und Frankreich.
Ähm dass man sich da jetzt auch bald einigen wird.
Und wenn's dann wirklich in eine zweite Welle reingeht und man weiß, dass das etwas ist, das sinnvoll ist, äh bei den Masken haben sich ja auch viele Leute gewehrt äh oder äh ist nicht cool gefunden.
Ähm und vielleicht, wenn die App sich wirklich bewährt äh und das auch Best Practices dafür gibt, äh kann man darüber wieder Vertrauen generieren.
Jetzt gibt's aber bei euch auch Diskussionen um Immunitätsausweise.
Genau, also ich ich wollte dieses Thema, eigentlich will ich das nur kurz ansprechen. Bei der letzten Sendung haben wir's äh äh nicht mehr untergebracht
ähm und eigentlich will ich äh,
immunisieren gegen den Immunitätsausweis. Ähm damit gemeint ist, äh die sehr schlechte Idee, dass man über irgendwelche Apps oder am schlimmsten noch über Blockchain ähm,
eine Information darüber, welche Menschen denn angeblich immun gegen äh Covid neunzehn sind, äh in die Welt bringt.
Und so ein Immunitätsausweis wurde in Österreich irgendwie früher diskutiert, weil wir hatten schon seit äh Dezember zwei neunzehn noch ein Gesetz herumliegen für einen elektronischen Impfpass
Das äh musste wieder behandelt werden und im Zuge dieser Debatte kam's dann auch zu einigen Wortmeldungen von Parteien. Wir brauchen jetzt unbedingt zu einem Immunitätsausweis,
Und wir haben äh laut geschrien, dass das eine ganz schlechte Idee wäre. Und die Gründe dafür sind eigentlich augenscheinlich. Also ich meine, die WHO warnt vor einem Immunitätsausweis aus dem einfachen Grund, weil die wissenschaftliche Basis fehlt,
Wir haben weder eine Impfung noch wissen wir, wie lange Immunität noch ausgestandener Krankheit überhaupt hält.
Also sprich äh wie eine Technik zu bauen für etwas, das medizinisch äh nicht bekannt ist, ist einfach Humbug.
Aber es gibt doch einige also es gibt dann so legitime Anwendungsfälle, wenn man reist wenn man einen Job mit Risikogruppe macht, zum Beispiel Altersheim oder Kindergarten, kann man argumentieren.
Aber da haben wir eigentlich schon brauchbare Lösungen. Es gibt Impfpässe,
Es gibt ärztliche Zertifikate über Impfungen. Ähm in vielen Ländern der Welt äh brauche ich die heute schon, um einreisen zu können.
Und auch bei gewissen Jobs werden die einfach verlangt. Dazu brauche ich keine App. Ähm was wir mit so einer App
aber bekämen, wer ein Haufen neuer Probleme ähm weil wenn's wirklich
einfach ist, so eine Immunität sichtbar zu machen, steigt der Anreiz anhand von dieser Immunität
auch zu diskriminieren. Ich glaube, Linus hat das eh schon, die Corona Hotel Geschäftsidee getauft, ähm genau in solche Probleme kommen wir hinein. Äh bis zu äh, dass man halt eben auf Dating-Apps irgendwie seine Corona-St.
Drinnen hat, bei Job-Interviews dazu gefragt wird. Ähm und.
Ja an sich ist äh wollte ich da nur nochmal aus der Perspektive nachschießen, dass man das wirklich lassen sollte,
und verweise auf unsere Stellungnahme zum elektronischen Impfers, die das nochmal in juristisch ausführt.
Okay, dann sind wir, glaube ich, langsam bei den ähm Kurzmeldungen angekommen. Es hat sich jetzt.
Nach diesen Verhaftungen in Münster gibt es jetzt weitere Verhaftungen, also in Münster wegen äh.
Missbrauch von Kindern und dem Vertrieb der Dokumentationen davon.
Und da gab es jetzt irgendwie kürzlich in Deutschland an in vier weiteren Bundesländern Untersuchungen mit hundertachtzig Beamten, die,
offensichtlich aufgrund des Materials, was sie da in Münster sichergestellt haben, nun,
auf weitere Täter ähm gelang äh gekommen sind. Ähm.
Irgendwo wurde auch gemeldet, dass es dass dabei dreißigtausend weitere Tatverdächtige sich aus diesem Material finden.
Was eine Zahl war, die natürlich sofort sehr viel Orte. Es gibt dreißigtausend Fälle von äh Kindesmisshandlung und so, ne? Und allein aus diesem münsteraner Fall, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe, hat Thorsten Kleinst, den ich als sehr.
Akribischen und genauen und penibelen Journalisten kenne, da dann mal nachgefragt und festgestellt, dass es sich nicht um.
Also nicht quasi Tatverdächtige, sondern Tatverdacht
Tatverdachts gab ging, ja, also nicht unbedingt um dreißigtausend Personen, sondern um dreißigtausend Hinweise auf einen,
Tatverdacht mit anderen Worten, da ist dann die da sind Duplikate jetzt nicht unbedingt ausgeschlossen. Und es sind nicht unbedingt so viele Personen, aber ähm da war die Meldung natürlich schon längst in der Welt.
Und egal ob die Einheit da jetzt äh Tatverdächtige oder Tatfälle, Tathergänge oder nur Hinweise sind, ähm ist sind das natürlich tatsächlich schockierende Zahlen.
Ähm ich hatte in den in der letzten Sendung auch nochmal über dieses diese Forschung und.
Themen gesprochen, die hier an der FU stattfinden, äh mit dem Projekt kein Täter werden, ja? Und da wurde in den Kommentaren erstens einmal noch mal auf die Webseite hingewiesen und zweitens auch auf ein Interview mit einer,
Forscherin, die in dem Bereich tätig sind, beides als ähm Fehlung in die Shownotes.
Als Empfehlung deshalb, weil ich denke, und das hatte ich auch schon beim letzten Mal gesagt, dass das die.
Neben der natürlich Strafverfolgung von Tätern ähm die sinnvolle der sinnvolle Ansatz zur Prävention ist.
Ähm ich habe noch ein ein Thema, was ähm.
Äh so noch vor den Kurzmeldungen ist, dass äh ziemlich erkloppbar ist, dass dass ähm hat in Österreich auch ziemlich wählen gemacht und zwar ähm ein Datenskandal. Äh manche sagen der größte Datenskandal, den es in Österreich jemals gab,
Ähm und zwar.
Chronologie ist ein bissel skurril, deswegen äh fange ich damit an. Also ähm wir bekamen irgendwie einen Anruf von den Neos, das ist die liberale Partei in Österreich, eigentlich eine sehr umtriebige Oppositionspartei.
Ähm und die kamen zu uns und sagten, hey, wir haben da dieses komische Register gefunden. Das äh ist vom Staat, das liegt da offen im Netz und irgendwie ist es ziemlich heftig, was man,
drinnen für Daten findet. Ähm da ist nämlich Name, Privatadresse, Geburtsdatum und auch
Datum von Steuererklärungen, von Wirtschaftsförderungen, von ähm allen von vom Bau
ähm ähm Einreichungen, die man gemacht hat, also wenn man ein Haus baut als Privatperson, all das findet sich da drinnen in diesem Register und es sind
grob eine Million Menschen konservativ geschätzt, die da offen im Netz stehen.
Wir haben uns das angeschaut und auch mal einerseits rechtlichen technisch geprüft und äh es stellte sich heraus, äh die Sorge ist berechtigt, ähm dieses Register erlaubte ähm,
einer Textsuche komplett ohne Capture, also man konnte da eingeben, Mord, Stern und hat.
Martins und alle Martinas in ganz Österreich bekommen,
Ähm es gab kein also man konnte da auch wirklich schön automatisiert die Daten von all diesen Menschen ähm abgreifen,
Ähm und wir wir haben dann angefangen zu graben, sind drauf gekommen, dass dieses Register
Zweitausendvier geschaffen wurde, also in einer sehr frühen äh Onlinezeit
und ähm die die ersten neun Jahre gab's da drin nur noch fünfzig Datensätze von Ministerien, äh irgendwelchen Dienststellen und Gemeinden und dann zweitausenddreizehn äh ist das angeschwollen, auf eins Komma vier Millionen Datensätze.
Weil man dann angefangen hat automatisiert Daten da reinzufüllen,
wie gesagt, wir reden eigentlich von ganz normalen Menschen, die sind da auch mit ihrem bürgerlichen Namen drinnen. Ähm.
Der eigentliche Grund, wieso die da drinnen sind, ist aber, weil sie selbstständige Einkünfte in den letzten Jahren hatten.
Und ist die komische Rechtsauffassung darauf, dass sie deswegen ein Unternehmen sind,
und ähm wer sich da auskennt, so juristische, natürliche Personen, also als Mensch, als natürlicher Person, habe ich Datenschutz.
Als Unternehmen oder Verein als juristische Person habe ich keinen Datenschutz. Und äh das wird hier zum Problem, äh weil nur weil ich jetzt irgendwie,
mal eine Honorarnote ausgestellt habe oder äh Prachteinnahmen, zehn Euro im Jahr habe oder freier Dienstnehmer bin, lande ich in diesem Register.
Und äh dieses Problem haben wir dann über mehrere Iterationen versucht ähm bei den zuständigen äh Digitalisierungsministerium abzustellen und auch dort um Verständnis geworben so
das ist wirklich gerade nicht okay wie das hier läuft und das ist ein Geschenk an alle Datenhändler dieser Welt sie haben sich
blind und taub gestellt und äh uns eher ignoriert und dann war irgendwie der Punkt, dass wir mit den Liberalen gemeinsam in einer Pressekonferenz äh rausgegangen sind.
Und äh dann kurz bevor äh diese Pressekonferenz war, hat man das Register vom vom äh Netz genommen. Ähm ich war dann an dem Abend auch noch in den Hauptnachrichten und bekam danach, äh gleich den Anruf aus dem.
Kabinette, Ministerin der Digitalisierungsministerin und wurde in einer Task Force geladen, in der ich mich dann die letzten eineinhalb Monate.
Ähm in mehreren Terminen äh mit einer Gruppe von anderen äh Beamten, aber auch äh Datenschutzexperten,
haben wir gemeinsam Empfehlungen erarbeitet, wie man dieses Ding äh verbessern kann,
Ähm äh ich sollte mal sagen, wie worum es geht. Es ist das Ergänzungsregister um sonstige Betroffene, was auch ein wunderschöner österreichischer Name ist äh für so einen Datenskandal. Und äh ja, das äh ist ziemlich
ähm heftig aus meiner Sicht, dass sowas über so viele Jahre möglich war, dass man da überhaupt keine ähm auch kein.
Problembewusstsein für den Datenschutz hatte.
Und ähm ich bin heiden froh, dass das jetzt abgestellt ist und äh warte aber schon auf die Reform, weil im Moment hat man das Register nur vom Netz genommen
ähm wie es damit weitergeht, ist durchaus noch etwas, das in Verhandlungen ist ähm und wo.
Man eben sich dann auch Gedanken machen muss, es ist wirklich richtig, dass jede Person, die eine
selbstständige Einkunft hat in irgendeinem Register ist, ohne dass sie darüber Bescheid bekommt, auch wenn man äh bei dem Register versucht hat, seine Privatadresse zum Beispiel ähm äh mit einer Geschäftsadresse zu löschen, hat das nichts gebracht, weil jeden Abend das Finanzministerium.
Automatisch die Daten überschrieben hat.
An die aktuelle Meldeadresse, die oft die private war, ähm stand dann wieder offen im Netz. Und man hatte da halt auch vom Bundespräsidenten abwärts, also ähm von von Alexander van der Bellen bis Heinz-Christian Strache, waren da alle drinnen
und da auch jeder Mensch, der irgendwie äh als Psychotherapeut arbeitet zum Beispiel. Also Leute, die wirklich auch vom Berufswegen her ähm,
ganz klar argumentieren können, wieso sie eine Sperre ihrer Privatadresse haben. Und in allen anderen Registern hält man sich auch an sowas, nur bei dem Register war's nicht der Fall.
Und ähm wir wissen auch nicht, ob die Daten nicht schon längst abgesaugt sind, also es gibt inzwischen ein paar ähm.
Darknet Leaks, äh die die jedoch einige Bitcoins kosten, die danach auch schon, als ob die Daten eh schon abgesaugt wären, was ein riesiger Data Bridge ist,
und ähm ultimativ stellt sich auch die Verantwortung, wieso gibt's solche Register, weil es ist die äh Stammzahlenregisterbehörde ähm Datenschutzrechtlich verantwortlich dafür, aber jede Gemeinde,
jedes Bauamt und das Finanzministerium haben alle Schreibzugriff auf diese Datenbank. Also so a bissel das Datenclou der Republik äh,
und es gibt keinerlei, ob das was da rein geschrieben wird, auch richtig ist. Es steht dann aber über diese Person im Netz. Ähm und äh eben Betroffenen Rechte, Zugriffsrechte, das ist alles nicht äh wirklich
durchdacht gewesen und ja, dieses Jahr wurde uns doch eine Reform versprochen und ich äh harre der Dinge wie ausgereift die sein wird.
Das war lustig auf jeden Fall so ein Datenskandal.
Datenklo der Republik. Alle mal reinschreiben.
Einfach da rum, also hat ihr wer hat die denn benutzt.
Also dieses Ergänzungsregister ist eben zweitausendvier, war
ist noch älter als das äh also bevor das Firmenbuch online kam, gab es schon dieses Ergänzungsregister. Und der Name sagt es schon, das ist eigentlich für die Sachen, die übrig bleiben, also für
natürliche Personen, für Menschen haben einen Melderegister in Österreich, wir haben ein Firmenbuch für alle Firmen und dann gibt's sonstige Betroffene,
das sind halt eben Gemeinden, andere Rechtspersönlichkeiten und eben auch theoretische äh Unternehmen, juristische Personen,
eben auch ein Personenunternehmen. Und äh
da hat man einfach nicht mitgedacht, dass die Wirtschaft sich so verändern wird, dass irgendwann einmal ganz viele Leute auch selbstständige Einkünfte haben oder in Jobverhältnissen, wie freier Dienstnehmer sind, wo sie da theoretisch drunterfallen,
und ähm er hat den Datenhahn aufgedreht und dann nie wieder drauf geschaut, wie viele da eigentlich drinnen sind.
Und ähm so ist das entstanden.
Oh Mann, na, das sind dann immer so diese diese Dinge, die dann irgendwann entdeckt werden.
Ja, ich habe jetzt ähm auch noch äh ihr, ihr mögt Österreicher für seine Kuriositäten. Und äh insofern habe ich noch zwei kleine Themen.
Wir lieben es dafür.
Es ist schön. Ähm eine eine Sache, die äh uns uns in Österreich sehr stark beschäftigt, äh wie wahrscheinlich überall auf der Welt sind die hohen Arbeitslosen. Äh und in Österreich gibt es seit einigen Jahren aber ein Projekt
des Arbeitsmarktservices, des AMS ähm äh,
Das äh ist das Äquivalent zu den Jobcentern in in Deutschland. Also die Stelle des Staates, die sich um arbeitslose Menschen kümmert. Und ähm die haben.
Sich vor einigen Jahren gedacht, es wäre doch cool, wenn wir nicht mehr die Berater hätten, die Menschen, die da irgendwie sich mühsam mit den Menschen auseinandersetzen müssen und entscheiden, wie hoch deren Jobchancen sind und wie viel wir noch in diesen Menschen investieren.
Sondern wenn ein Computer entscheidet.
Äh was die Jobchancen von diesem arbeitssuchenden Menschen sind. Und ähm dann hat man einen Algorithmus gebaut, den IMS-Agorithmus.
Der ähm fortan eine Entscheidungshilfe sein soll, ob es überhaupt noch sinnvoll ist in diesen Menschen zu investieren.
Und äh dieser AMS-Agorithmus ist ein Computerprogramm, über das sehr wenig Bescheid ist, also wir,
nur einen von über sechzig verschiedenen Algorithmen, die da zur Anwendung kommen. Aber der eine, den wir kennen, der ist äh recht äh aussagekräftig, weil der hat zum Beispiel so tolle Sachen wie ähm
aha, du bist über fünfzig Jahre alt, gleich mal ein Abzug von deinen Jobchancen. Hast zu Hause jemand, um den du dich kümmern musst, dein Kind, eine alte Person und du bist eine Frau,
Abzug deiner Jobchancen. A du bist ähm nicht in,
Österreich geboren und auch nicht in Europa geboren, auch nochmal gleich ein Abzug deiner Jobchancen,
äh auch wenn du perfekt Deutsch kannst. Das ist dem Algorithmus egal. Also er hat auf mehreren Ebenen
Diskriminierungen, auch Behinderungen sind eine äh ein Nachteil in diesem Algorithmus, also alles, was dich körperlich einschränkt ähm und,
Es ist halt ein mehr oder weniger hat man alles falsch gemacht, was man nur falsch machen kann bei so Algorithmen, die über Menschen entscheiden. Ähm.
In der Summe äh werden die Arbeitssuchenden in drei Kategorien einsortiert, äh die gute, mittlere und schlechten Jobchancen und eigentlich kriegen nur die mittleren Förderungen,
den guten und bei den schlechten ähm sortiert man aus äh und da äh gibt's halt auch viele Leute, die vom Computer,
abgestempelt werden und äh dann auch keine Förderungen, keine Aus- und Weiterbildungen mehr bekommen.
So nach dem Motto, die Guten, die finden schon alleine was und die Schlichten werden wir eh nie los.
Also man sagt dann natürlich, das ist die effektive Aufteilung der äh begrenzten Ressourcen einer Weiterbildung auf die ähjenigen, die am wahrscheinlichsten auch von dieser Weiterbildung profitieren.
Und das AMS sagt auch, ähm na ja, der Algorithmus mag vielleicht diskriminieren, aber unsere Berater diskriminieren ja auch.
Arbeitsmarkt diskriminiert halt einfach gegen Frauen, die zu Hause ein Kind haben, dass sie pflegen müssen oder einen Angehörigen und äh so versucht man,
das zu argumentieren, wobei der größte Teil des Algorithmus die anderen Modelle äh ist sowieso komplett intransparent über die wissen wir fast gar nichts. Ähm
Es ist keine vollautomatisierte Entscheidung, also es sitzt immer noch ein Mensch da, aber dem wird halt angezeigt, was der Algorithmus meint
Ähm diese Mitarbeiterinnen sind aber überhaupt nicht drauf geschult und wir wissen von einem ähnlichen System in Polen, dass von zweihundert,
solcher Fälle nur ein einziges Mal die Sachbearbeiter gegen den Algorithmus, gegen den Computer entscheiden. Also.
Und das war dann Vetternwirtschaft.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ähm also all diese Missstände haben uns dazu gebracht, eine neue Kampagne zu starten, AMS-Agorithmus AT ähm mit sieben Forderungen und äh auch einem wunderwunderbaren äh Video von Alexander Lehmann
Animationskünstler der Netzpolitik, der ja schon an allen möglichen Videos, du bist Terrorist und Uploadfilter bewiesen hat, wie gut er komplexe Themen rüberbringt
Ähm und ähm ja auf der Webseite kann man eine Petition unterschreiben, ein Auskunftsersuchen über die eigenen,
stellen, wenn man in Österreich schon mal einen arbeitssuchend war. Ähm das ist ein besonders toller
weil das äh ist sehr aufwendig fürs AMS. Die haben leider keinen Prozess, um äh Auskunft das Suchen zu beantworten. Insofern ist es ein schöner Weg, sie zu ärgern. Und man kann natürlich auch der politisch verantwortlichen Arbeitsministerin Aschbacher
über unsere Webseite schreiben und ähm das ist so eine Empfehlung äh für alle Menschen, die in Österreich schon mal arbeitslos fahren oder die das ärgert.
Oder die nicht mehr wissen, ob sie schon mal arbeitslos in Österreich waren. Das könnte ihnen das AMS ja dann sagen mit der Datenauskunft.
Genau. Es ist ja auf jeden Fall muss ja auf Nummer sicher gehen, hm?
Irgendeiner komischen Register für übrig gebliebene auf einmal sich wiederfindet. Also ich finde diese Sache mit diesem Algorithmus.
Also problematisch daran sind, sind sind ja zwei Dinge.
A, dass wenn so ein Algorithmus einmal eine Entscheidung trifft, ne, das ist das typische Computer-Sess No, dann ist es einfach für die Sachbearbeiterin oder den Sachbearbeiter schwieriger.
Äh jetzt einen anderen Weg zu gehen, als das, was dieses System vorschlägt. Und deswegen weicht man davon nicht ab. Ähm.
Ist es gleichzeitig also das macht es,
Das nimmt im Prinzip ein bisschen die Hoheit der Sachbearbeiterinnen weg. Und den den Spielraum, das kann gut oder das kann schlecht sein. Ähm gewissermaßen so etwas maschinell zu machen.
Ja schafft halt eine Gleichbehandlung nach den wenigen Kriterien, nach denen sie stattfindet so, ne? Und.
Prinzip ist doch das, worüber man sich eigentlich hier ärgern muss, diese.
Kriterien. Nur wenn du dich an denen abarbeiten möchtest, musstest du bessere vorschlagen. Und.
Natürlich ist es für den Staat nicht wünschenswert, irgendwelche Leute mit Förderungen zu segnen, die auch ohne irgendwelche Förderungen und Weiterbildungen einfach wieder in einen Job kommen
Und natürlich ist es auch für einen Staat ein Problem, sagen wir mal, äh Menschen zu fördern, die eben letztendlich nicht vermittelbar sind.
Ähm aus welchem Grund auch immer. Insofern.
Finde ich, also so es ist es ist, glaube ich, sehr sehr wichtig, da diese Transparenz zu bekommen. Ähm und diesen Algorithmus halt hundertprozentig verstanden zu haben. Ähm ich
bin mir tatsächlich nicht sicher und wir hatten ja vor einigen vor einiger Zeit schon in unserer ähm in unserer Folge von der vom.
Von der Privacy Week in Wien darüber gesprochen. Ähm ich also ist es besser, wenn die Entscheidung wieder Menschen treffen.
Ja
Also ich finde ein ein ein Computer sollte nicht über ein menschliches Schicksal entscheiden, gerade wenn es im staatlichen Bereich ist, das ist zu heikel, da geht es um Zugang zu staatlichen Leistungen, Gesundheit
Sicherheit. Ich will da keine,
schlecht gemachten Algorithmen haben, die die Anforderungen an an solche Systeme müssen so hoch sein.
Das sehe ich äh fast keine IT im öffentlichen Bereich der Zeitung definitiv nicht dieses System. Eine unserer Forderungen ist auch, Risikocheck für Algorithmen, da gibt's auch gute Systeme in New York, in Kanada, wie man so Risikochecks machen kann.
Aber ultimativ glaube ich, dass die Menschen ein Recht darauf haben, dass ein staatliches Handeln nachvollziehbar ist
und das ein Mensch über sie entscheidet ähm und und eben nicht ein ein Computerprogramm, das eine komplette Black Box ist.
Dann aber entscheidet, wie dein Schicksal und dein Einkommen für die nächsten X Jahre sein wird. Ähm also ich,
ich habe ich habe auf der Ebene ein Problem damit. Und auf der anderen Ebene habe ich noch viel größeres Problem. Wenn wir das jetzt hier zulassen und wenn das so bleibt.
Dann ist alle sind's jeder künftige Sozial- oder Arbeitsmarkt-Reform nur noch ein Softwareupdate. Also.
Nach den solchen Algorithmen dann Entscheidungen treffen.
Ähm sind einer demokratischen Debatte ja auch fast nicht mehr zugänglich. Also auch für das Problem könnte ich noch reine gute Lösung benennen,
deswegen, ich bin insgesamt auf einer stark ablehnenden Haltung und ich finde einfach, dieses System im Konkreten ist so schlecht gemacht, dass man's auch einfach abschalten muss.
Mhm, also ich ich verstehe schon den, ich verstehe schon den Punkt. Ich denke halt, also.
Dass du eventuell unterschätzt, wie groß das Problem von Willkür und solchen Dingen in diesem Bereich ist. Ähm.
Wir haben das mal oder ich habe da vor mehreren Jahren mal eine Stellungnahme zugeschrieben. Da ging's um im Prinzip diese Risikomanagementsysteme, die ähm in der in der im Besteuerungs,
gerecht zum Einsatz kommen. Da ging's im Prinzip darum, mit einem Algorithmus entscheiden zu lassen, wer eine Steuerprüfung bekommt.
Und da war meine Kernargumentation, warum man das nicht tun sollte oder was das Problem eines solchen Systems ist, dass.
Die Kriterien, nach denen es auswählt, im Prinzip nicht gleich verteilt sind über die Steuersünderinnen.
Ja, also du machst ja eigentlich eine Steuerprüfung, ähm um Menschen zu überführen, die Fehlangaben in ihrer Steuer.
In ihrer Steuererklärung haben, um denen dann noch mehr Geld wegzunehmen.
Ja, das ist der äh das ist die Idee dahinter. Und diese Risikosysteme äh können auch zum Beispiel darauf getunt werden.
Eben möglichst ertragreich zu operieren. Das heißt, du kannst da über relativ einfache Kriterien, zum Beispiel, ne, es könnte zum Beispiel dazu führen, dass du.
Erstens ähm Gutverdiener eher steuerprüfst als Schlechtverdienende, was eine fürchterliche Benachteiligung für.
Gutverdienende wäre, tatsächlich nicht rechtens, ja? Das war in dieser der Anhörung damals das große Thema, ne? Ich meine, selbstverständlich wäre es sinnvoll, äh Steuerprüfungen bei den Leuten zu machen, die viel Geld haben, weil man da wahrscheinlich auch noch viel mehr Geld für den Staat bekommt.
Ist aber äh ähm verstößt aber gegen den Gleichbehandlungsgrundsatz. Und der andere Aspekt war äh
denen ich viel wichtiger finde, dass du ja in einer Situation sein könntest, dass du spezifische Formen der Steuerhinterziehung
schneller entdeckst als andere. Zum Beispiel, wenn das System einfach sagt, alles klar, wir äh konzentrieren uns auf die Gastronomie
dann dann könntest du würdest du irgendwann sagen, wunderbar, seitdem wir dieses System einsetzen und die ganzen Restaurants fertigmachen, denen können wir bei den Steuerprüfungen immer noch mal irgendwie einen Espresso finden, den sie verschenkt haben und nicht ordentlich gebucht haben oder so.
Und du würdest eventuell, du weißt nicht, ob dein System optimal arbeitet.
Ähm und da war im Prinzip meine Argumentation dann zu sagen, wenn ihr schon so etwas macht, dann müsst ihr wenigstens dieses System halt selbst lernen und verifizieren, sich selbst verifizierend. Mein Vorschlag da war zu sagen, okay,
Das Ding darf halt, was weiß ich, nach Kriterien die Hälfte aussuchen.
Und die andere Hälfte der Prüfung muss es ganz einfach äh nach Zufall würfeln, sodass du verhinderst, dass dieses System blinde Flecken entwickelt. Und das wäre doch.
Eventuell, ja, wenn man jetzt, wie gesagt, wir wollen Algorithmus gesteuert, ähm im Arbeitsmarkt optimieren.
Da gibt's ja noch viel ganz andere Fragen außer irgendwelchen Förderungen, geht's ja auch zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, wen bezahlst du denn Umzug, ne? Lohnt es sich? Ist es sinnvoll.
Dass dieser Elektroingenieur nach Stuttgart umzieht. Ja, oder ist es sinnvoll, dass diese ähm.
Was weiß ich, diese Architektin nach Berlin umzieht. Ähm das also das das eigentliche Kriterium.
Was was du dann hast, äh das erfassen diese Systeme ja nicht. Und ich glaube, das macht die eigentlich so gefährlich, dass die nicht unbedingt ihre eigene, die Effizienz ihrer eigenen.
Überlegungen überhaupt in Frage stellen können oder die dieses Feedback bekommen. Und das wäre doch eigentlich.
Für so ein System und hier scheint es so zu sein, dass sie einfach quasi Apriori sagen, so kategorien wir die Menschen und nicht nachher gucken, ob das sinnvoll oder richtig war.
Ja? Also ich glaube, äh wo ich dir zustimmen, ist so irgendwie der Wert von Daten zur Qualitäts ähm.
Bestimmung, Qualitätsteigerung und überhaupt auch mal herauszufinden, was in deinem Laden läuft. Und das ist auch für staatliche Stellen, glaube ich, wichtig, aber da, das sehe ich immer hauptsächlich in so einer.
Sollte man auch mit den Menschen machen zum Beispiel, ne? Also egal, wer da eine Entscheidung trifft.
Also was was bei dem System zum Beispiel spannend mal zu diskutieren wäre, ist, wenn das im Nachhinein kommt, Beraterin, Berater entscheidet und dann kommt der Algorithmus
ist aber nicht etwas, das zusätzlich in Baiers reinbringt, sondern versucht den Baiers der Beraterinnen zu korrigieren. Oder sichtbar zu machen. Ähm
Damit es eben nicht nur die Willkür der einzelnen Personen ist, das wären gänzlich anderes System. Ähm also überall da, wo du Daten verwendest, umso expost, also im Nachhinein nachzuschauen
hat das jetzt hier wirklich was gebracht oder was war denn wirklich der Effekt davon? Was ist der Baiers, mit dem wir gerade operieren? Da finde ich das super wertvoll, aber,
An dem Punkt in der Welt, wo wir gerade sind, ist alles an Vergleichsdatenmaterial, was du hast Corona.
Sprich komplett irrelevant. Also gerade der Arbeitsmarkt äh wird sich so umstrukturieren durch diese Krise, dass ich nicht glaube, dass jetzt ein ein auch nur Teilautomatisiertes System der richtige Weg ist.
Und das Beispiel von Polen, was ich gebracht habe, zweihundert Entscheide, wenn ein einziges Mal hat man sich hat man dem Computer widersprochen, ähm,
Das polnische System wurde vom Höchstgericht auch aufgehoben.
Und ist dort nicht mehr im äh Arbeitsmarkt in den Jobcentern im Einsatz. Also ähm ich ich glaube schon, dass wir hier auch ebenso in Bezug auf Nachvollziehbarkeit von staatlichem Handeln hohe Ansprüche stellen müssen.
Und ähm,
uns geht's mit der Kampagne auch einfach mal drum, so diese rote Linie zu ziehen, damit wir nicht auch noch in zig anderen Bereichen Algorithmen im staatlichen Handeln sehen und deswegen auch diese Petition, um politischen Druck für für diese rote Linie an sich mal
ähm aufzubauen. Ähm
Ich habe wirklich Angst, dass das sonst der neue Standard wird äh wie man in in in der öffentlichen Hand so Systeme designt.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall ein, also ne, klar, es es geht rucki zucki in eine riesige Problembereiche. Da bin ich, da bin ich auf jeden Fall auch bei dir.
Ganz klar. Und aber es macht auch tatsächlich mal Sinn, sich über diese Kriterien, die diese Systeme anwenden.
Trotzdem mal Gedanken zu machen, weil das sind ja am Ende politische Maßgaben, politische Entscheidungen, ne? Bis wann fördere ich Leute noch,
wie viel wie welche wie große Teil dieser Gesellschaft
hänge ich einfach ab, säge ich einfach ab als äh kriegst nix mehr, brauchst dir auch keine Gedanken mehr zu machen, dass wir dich nochmal in irgendein, irgendwo nochmal in einer Lohn und Brot bringen, dass du in der
irgendwie eine angemessene gesellschaftliche Teilhabe in deinem Leben nochmal erlangst. Und da musst du dich natürlich auch nicht wundern, ähm was die Menschen dann.
Für Vorstellungen entwickeln und wie die, ich meine, die müssen auch ihren Tag rumbringen, ne?
Also eben da, wo's dann wirklich um um äh du bist jetzt abgehängt äh ich meine das Ausstoßen von Menschen äh,
das passiert in unserer Gesellschaft, das dürfen wir nicht, nicht schönreden und das ist vor allem auch in in Europa zu sehen ein Problem, aber ich finde halt immer,
Dahinter steckt so die die philosophische Frage, ist es jetzt besser oder schlechter, wenn Computer oder ein Mensch gegen dich diskriminiert? Ja,
Ich finde halt schon, wenn's einen Computer macht, ist es nochmal schlimmer, weil es ist systemischer, es ist automatisierter. Ähm aber ja im Grunde ist es eine philosophische Frage.
Ähm ich habe noch ein anderes schönes Thema. Das ist ein kurzer Klopper, einfach nur normalerweise wäre das genau die Art von Tee, immer die die Linus äh ansprechen würde und sich wunderbar darüber aufregen. Ähm
das Projekt Edelstein in Österreich. Ist etwas, das über eine Recherche mehrerer Medien, Profilstandard und
ORF herauskam. Ähm das ist ein geheimes Projekt im Finanzministerium in Österreich gewesen. Ähm.
Dass zweitausendachtzehn, neunzehn, also noch unter der türkisblauen Regierung unter Beteiligung der FPÖ und der ÖVP. Also der Konservativen und der der rechtsextremen Partei. Ähm äh geplant hat, das Bundesrechenzentrum zu privatisieren.
Das Bundesrechenzentrum ist so der Hort aller Daten in Österreich. Also das ist,
Steuer, Melderregister, alle Gesundheitsdaten, der elektronische Akt, also alles, was irgendwie bei der Polizei ist, ist im Bundesrechnungszentrum.
Und ähm die kritische Infrastruktur der der gesamten Bundes-IT hätte man laut diesem Plan an die Post AG,
verkaufen wollen. Ähm das Ganze war ein geheimer Plan, nicht mal der Koalitionspartner wusste davon, es stand auch nicht im Regierungs äh
Programm, aber das Vorhaben hat es im Finanzministerium überdauert auch in die Übergangsregierung, nachdem mit Ibiza ja die die letzte Regierung in Österreich zu Fall
gebracht wurde und äh das Ganze war sogar so konkret, dass man schon die notwendigen Gesetzesänderungen vorbereitet hat.
Wie wieso ist das jetzt schlimm? Die die Post ist in Österreich ein Aktien notierter Adresshändler.
Und der größte Datensünder, den wir haben, also die Post hat erst zweitausendneunzehn eine achtzehn Millionen,
Euro Strafe für ein riesiges äh Datenschutzvergehen äh aufgebrummt bekommen.
Ähm und insofern der all denkbar schlechteste Betreiber von allen sensiblen Daten äh der öffentlichen Hand.
Äh ich ich wollte dieses.
Ja, Beispiel eigentlich nur noch mal bringen, um auch mal zu zeigen, wie auf wie vielen Ebenen das falsch ist. Einerseits mal so die Frage, können wir die IT der öffentlichen Hand vertrauen? Und die Daten, die der Staat über uns hat.
Auf der anderen Seite noch, dass es super wichtig ist, dass es auch eine IT-Kompetenz gibt, ähm,
auf die die öffentliche Hand zugreifen kann und das Bundesrechenzentrum
ähm ist auf jeden Fall äh in Österreich einer der Stellen, die sich auskennt, ähm wie man ähm solche Softwareprojekte aufsetzt, auch wie man
ähm Hosting betreibt und wie man Dinge sicher macht und wie man Dinge auch skaliert. Und äh da kriegt man halt auch eine eher ungefärbtere Sache. Exper
dieser als wenn man zu irgendeinem Berater geht. Alles wäre natürlich auch nochmal,
ein Schritt weg von dem, was wir eigentlich grad bräuchten, nämlich mehr IT im Gemeininteresse, die eben nicht nur privatwirtschaftlichen Bestrebungen folgt.
Ähm und ja und zuletzt ist es natürlich auch nochmal ein sehr deutliches Signal
welchen Stellenwert Datenschutz ähm bei der ÖVP hat, also bei dem konservativen in Österreich äh weil so ein Projekt sich auszudenken hat schon fast was Diabolisches und deswegen wollte ich's einfach hier
nochmal ansprechen.
Wie viel haben die denn gespendet?
Das wissen wir leider nicht. Ähm wir haben immer noch kein gescheites Transparenz oder Parteienfinanzierungsgesetz und ähm ja aber die Spender der ÖVP sind viele.
Oh Mann ey. Immer wenn wir denken, wir hätten gerade ein Korruptionsproblem, dann denkt man an Österreich und dann ist wieder gut.
Ja, wir sind ein reiches Land. Äh.
Reich an die Dehnt.
Oh ja.
Ja, dann will ich mal ein äh Thema ansprechen, weil du dich wahrscheinlich wieder schämst, es anzusprechen
trotzdem haben wir es hier in unserer äh Liste. Ihr könntet ein bisschen Geld gebrauchen bei EpiCenterworks, um all diese äh ausführlichen Tätigkeiten weiter durchführen zu können
sie sich ja jetzt hier auch gerade wieder dargestellt haben. Stimmt's?
Ja, ach danke für den Hinweis, Tim, haha.
Ähm ja also äh Österreich ist reich, wir sind aber arm, weil wir unabhängig sind und wir leben wirklich ja von Spenden seit vielen Jahren und dieses Jahr auch bedingte,
Corona und das Wegbrechen mehrerer internationaler Stiftungen und Fördergeber ähm ist es wirklich eng.
Und äh nach jetziger Maßgabe werden wir das aktuelle Jahr nicht überleben. Und deswegen haben wir ähm jetzt grade so ein eine Kampagne am Laufen, äh wo wir die Leute bitten, Fördermitglied zu werden, damit wir
als irgendwie durchschaffen und ähm die Arbeit einfach fortsetzen können. Wir haben viel vor, Digital Services act
ist so das größte Thema an dem wir arbeiten werden, wo's auch eine Kampagne von uns geben wird ähm und vieles habe ich jetzt eh schon genannt, also es ist.
Genug zu tun und das kann man nicht nur in Freizeit machen und dafür braucht man hauptamtliche Leute und ähm,
damit wir das Jahr überleben äh ist es noch so ungefähr ein Delta von äh siebenundfünfzigtausend Euro, die wir bräuchten und die Kampagne läuft noch bis äh,
wahrscheinlich November, Dezember, je nachdem wie es sich halt ausgeht. Ich hoffe eigentlich auch aufgrund der der Aufmerksamkeit der letzten ähm.
Wochen, die ja sehr hoch war auf uns, dass es sich schon ausgehen wird. Aber ähm
Wenn ihr uns auch wirklich dabei unterstützen wollt, äh der Link ist in den Shownotes und wer ein bissel mehr gibt, kriegt auch Goodie Bags mit so Arapeschutzhüllen, coolen T-Shirts und äh Corona-Masken, was auch immer man haben will. Also es ist,
Es gibt zumindest auch ein gutes Gefühl und ein Stück Freiheit dafür.
Wie ist das eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt als äh deutscher Deutsch äh spende? Ähm kann ich das irgendwie hier in Deutschland steuerlich gelten?
Kannst du nicht.
Leider nein. Äh steuerliche Absetzbarkeit ist ein schwieriges Thema, das ist europäisch nicht harmonisiert. Ähm und die,
Die kurze Antwort ist nein, auch weil ähm wir in Österreich keine steuerliche Begünstigung genießen, ganz einfach, weil Demokratie und Grundrechte in Österreich nicht begünstigt sind, nur
Tiere und alte Leute und ähm Entwicklungshilfe. Ähm und ja, das.
Kenne ich irgendwo her.
Ist ein Problem, das wir hier schon mal haben in Österreich und bei der das dann überhaupt in Deutschland auch anrechnen zu lassen, äh ist schwierig. Ähm deswegen kurze Antwort,
geht leider einfach nicht, können wir nicht anbeten. Liegt aber nicht an uns. Ähm wir können natürlich trotzdem Spendenbestätigungen ausstellen für alles, was wir erhalten. Ähm aber äh das ist bei der Steuer nicht mindernd geltend zu machen.
Unsere Freunde von übermorgen hatten nochmal dieses schöne äh Kunstprojekt Vote äh Exchange
wo wo man so Stimmtausch äh äh organisieren konnte, um sie an anderen vielleicht sollte man auch mal so ein Spenden äh
Portal machen, so nach dem Motto, wenn du in Österreich was äh spendest, spende ich dann sozusagen an die an die deutsche äh Organisation, die du eigentlich bedenken wolltest und dann kriegt jeder sozusagen sein
seine Ermäßigung und äh alle das Geld.
Ja, wobei, ich bin mir nichts.
Bestimmt wieder total illegal, mein Vorschlag, aber finde ich irgendwie gerade ganz charmant, weil das stimmt, ne? Also da habe ich noch nie so drüber nachgedacht, aber wir haben im Prinzip das Prinzip der Gemeinnützigkeit auf europäischer Ebene, so nicht.
Und das ist natürlich doof, weil grade wenn's um europäische Belange geht und um die kümmert ihr euch ja nun auch, ne? Seid ihr im Prinzip ja ausschließlich auf Spenden aus Österreich.
Also könnt ihr nur für Spenden auf aus Österreich diese Gemeinnützigkeit und damit diese Spendenverrechnungsfähigkeit bieten und das ist ja unangemessen.
Finde ich.
Das ist ein großes Problem und da hat die EU halt einfach auch noch nicht auf ähm den den Wert der Zivilgesellschaft geachtet, ja. Also ich meine, ich finde das super schade, weil äh viele der Probleme auch in Polen und Ungarn, die wir so,
haben auch mit einem fehlenden Zivilgesellschaft zu tun und ab einer gewissen Problemintensität,
kostet das halt einfach Geld und die, die Möglichkeiten,
für so was auch auf europäischer Ebene sind, einfach nicht da. Bei Edri merke ich, dass äh auch ganz massiv, wo ich auch im Vorstand bin und,
die sind halt einfach super abhängig von Stiftungen.
Zum Glück ähm ist äh die EU inzwischen so wichtig, dass sich das ausgeht, aber ich fände es auch schöner, wenn Edri aus von Spenden getragen wird. Äh und äh das zu organisieren ist aber super mühsam. Wir haben zumindest
Team Euro und mit dem SEPA-System eine Möglichkeit, Zahlungen,
Euro abzuwickeln, ohne große Transaktionsgebühren. Also da kannst du sechs Cent auch äh hin und her schicken und das kostet keinerlei Gebühr, kein Reibungsverlust, den Teil hast du, aber diese Spendenabsetzbarkeit, das ist ähm.
Wirklich was, das in in vielen Ländern national nicht gut gelehnt ist und keineswegs so, dass man äh europäische Arbeit wirklich auch aus ganz Europa heraus ähm finanzieren und honorieren könnte.
Tja, da ist man sich einfach noch nicht einig, wie man das dann macht, ne. Ja, da sind wir durch, oder?
Ja, dann äh sind wir durch mit unserem Podcast für sonstige Betroffene.
Und äh müssen uns jetzt echt auch kurz über das Auto gleich zanken, denke ich. Ähm.
Ich bin ja wirklich so eine ein Trauer, ein trauriges Lied für unseren lieben Herrn Tönnies.
Auch wenn du das immer wieder in unsere Schulung so reinschreibst, unser Outro ist nichts Auto, es ist ein Bonustreck, es gibt extra.
Okay, das äh.
Outrow arbeiten wir noch.
Ich wollte jetzt extra äh ich wollte äh extra bevor das jetzt ein Bonustrack ist, ich weiß nicht, wie das rechtlich ist, aber wieso wieso sind Punker den kann man ja wohl mal irgendwie die werden ja jetzt nicht uns verklagen, aber wir.
Wir Raubmord kopieren das mal kurz.
Machen wir. Nein, wir wir helfen dem, wir verhelfen dem zu neuem Glanz.
Jetzt habt ihr's auch noch zugegeben, jetzt können wir uns noch nicht mal mehr rausreden. Toll.
Fair used, fair use.
Thomas, vielen Dank.
War schön, danke.
Ja
Ich würde auch noch kurz danken und zwar dem Oliver. Ähm und einer unbekannten Person und wenn ich einer unbekannten Person danke, dann ist damit ja immer meine Bitte verbunden, sich doch mal bei mir zu melden.
Bitte melde dich genau. Vielen Dank auch für eure ähm Spenden und Daueraufträge, die ihr gestartet und durchgehalten und teilweise ergänzt und erweitert habt. All das hilft uns hier sehr weiter. Äh,
lasst den Spenden R nie, nie unter eins fallen und.
Das war's für diese Woche. Wir sehen uns dann nächste Woche wieder. Bis bald.